Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen Tim.
Ich glaube, diese Sendung hat so viel Veröffentlichungspotential, die wird bestimmt bald wieder gelöscht.
Die wird nicht lange online bleiben, wir müssen auf jeden Fall unseren alternativen Kanal und unsere Veröffentlichung erwähnen und folgt uns in unserem Telegram-Kanal, unbedingt.
Lokbuch, Netzpolitik Nummer dreihundertneunundneunzig. Da brauche ich hundertneunundneunzig, die Spannung steigt und ähm
Bevor wir auf was auch immer die vierhundert sind, gehen, dachten wir uns, machen wir nochmal ein kleines Spezial zwischendurch, haben wir sonst nichts zu tun, ne.
Genau und wir haben vor allem ein Thema äh identifiziert.
Zudem wir relativ viele Fragen bekommen, auch so ja in Kommentaren und Mails.
Und dass wir noch nie so wirklich abschließend behandelt haben, insbesondere auch ähm in der letzten Sendung, dass nochmal festgestellt haben. Und darüber geht es einfach um den Messenger.
Telegramm.
Genau. Telegramm und überhaupt die ganze äh Frage von bösen Kanälen im Internet und wo lauert das böse und was tun wir dagegen? Und da wir da überhaupt keinerlei Kompetenz haben, wie ihr ja wisst,
haben wir uns äh noch den Max eingeladen, nämlich Max, hallo Max.
Max, du bist Journalist, das kann man, glaube ich, äh so festhalten, ne. Wie bist du denn dazu gekommen?
Journalismus ähm bin ich,
eigentlich gekommen, ähm als beziehungsweise Journalist, würde ich sagen, also mich interessieren so alle Themen irgendwie an der Schnittstelle von von Technik und Gesellschaft und weiß nicht, ob man's schon für Technik und,
Internet und was da so passiert äh interessiert und ähm dann irgendwann festgestellt, dass es einfach in der öffentlichen Debatte total wenig.
Beleuchtet wird, die Politik oft wenig auf dem Schirm hat oder nicht korrekt auf dem Schirm hat, was da passiert und.
Dann ähm haben wir an den deutschen Ableger von dem Tech-Magazin Motherboard von ähm Weiß gegründet. Das war zweitausend ähm dreizehn, kurz nach den.
Snowden-Enthüllung und das war irgendwie.
Ja, das war irgendwie so ein Portal, wo wir halt irgendwie Geschichten erzählen wollten, kenntnisreich oder Berichterstattung, kenntnisreich irgendwie übers Internet. Gleichzeitig kritisch, aber gleichzeitig auch nicht die Technik irgendwie so,
verteufeln, das hat man ja auch manchmal, wenn's um um Tech-Portale geht äh und Berichterstattung, ähm also jetzt nicht,
Medien speziell, sondern so große Tech Medien. Genau und irgendwie so ähm ging's dann immer weiter zwischen.
Spiegel ähm als Journalist und ja, einfach mache gerne Recherche zu komplizierten Dingen im Internet.
Aber was er denn schon immer äh computeraffin oder ist das jetzt eher etwas, was du dir so übergeholfen hast?
Ich war irgendwie schon immer so Internetkultur affin, würde ich sagen. Also das wirklich so seit seit Jugendzeiten, dass ich irgendwie ja, einfach Internetkultur, Netzkultur, alles, was da passiert. So spannend fand ich mir jetzt nicht der,
absolute äh Programmierer oder so, das nicht.
Du hast mir so mehme gepostet auf Fortschalten und so.
Sozusagen, genau. Äh steht im Lebenslauf, äh Beispiel, Meme of Ford.
Ja, ich meine, das das ist ja in der Tat auch schon wirklich eine eine valide ähm,
Kompetenz, ne, die die sicherlich vielen total abgeht so. Ich meine, unsere äh oder meine Generation viel mehr.
Sind ja so äh was weiß ich, so diese diese frühkindliche Beschäftigung hat ja quasi intensive technische Basisarbeit überhaupt vorausgesetzt, um überhaupt,
ganze nutzbar zu machen, während's halt später dann alles schon sich soweit äh entfaltet hat, dass die Art und Weise, wie man jetzt mit diesem Netz tanzt,
auf viele Arten äh erfolgen kann und ich fand grad so diese ganze Auseinandersetzung als kulturelles Phänomen, äh hatte dann schon doch noch mal so eine eigene Qualität und.
Aber auch so ein.
Wissen über das Netz, wenn man das jetzt überhaupt nicht hat oder sich's nicht zumindest mal ansatzweise herangeführt hat, dann versteht man ja auch einfach gar vieles nicht mehr oder man versteht potenziell auch so vieles falsch.
Total und dann muss man wieder bei nachgucken und da stehen dann wieder sieben Erklärungen von den fünf nicht richtig sind und drei fehlen. Ähm.
Aber das ist halt, da steckt auch genau so diese Ambivalenz drin, ne, die ich halt auch äh total spannend finde, also das ist
glaube ich oft in Deutschland die Perspektive, vielleicht ändert sich das auch ein bisschen, aber lange gewesen in der öffentlichen Debatte, so die Technik zu zu verteufeln.
Und zu zu kritisieren und zu sagen, das ist alles schlecht, aber ich meine jetzt grade Memes und so, das ist also man kann mit nicht vielen Sachen, man kann mit vielen Sachen mehr Spaß haben, aber man kann mit München auch ziemlich viel Spaß haben.
Ähm,
aber gleichzeitig die Orte, an denen die entstehen, sind natürlich manchmal auch total düster so und es es kommt halt darauf an, wie wir mit der Technik umgehen und dass wir irgendwie wissen, was da passiert und da irgendwie als Gesellschaft eine realistische Einschätzung.
Und das war dann irgendwie auch so für mich das Ding, wo ich gemerkt habe, okay, das ist halt echt ein Thema, wo man viel drüber berichten und sich angucken kann und es ist irgendwie spannend, ähm.
Hast du, was ist denn dein Eindruck, wie, sagen wir mal, zumindest der Deutsche journalistische, die journalistische Branche da aufgeholt hat, also wie gut hat äh der Journalismus ähm das Netz im Blick mittlerweile.
Ich glaube, es gibt selten noch irgendwie Killerspieldebatten, das ist ja so das unsäglichste Beispiel für.
Ist so eine total Technik ähm äh ja absurderweise auch eine total technikgläubige Position, ne, wo man sagt, A Computerspiel A geht ins Gehirn des Menschen über, ah Killer, also A so Amoklauf,
mal ganz banal runtergebrochen. Ich glaube, das gibt's irgendwie.
Selten nur noch, es gibt schon echt viele gute Portale und auch viele gute junge Journalistinnen, Journalisten, die sich diese Themen.
Angucken, gleichzeitig habe ich das Gefühl, dass da immer noch total viel,
und und Raum wäre, was passiert einfach so viel Spannendes im Netz und mit dem Netz und ähm.
Ja, das wird auch irgendwie nicht mehr.
Weniger offensichtlicher Weise und ich glaube, dass wir immer noch nicht genug aufgeklärt sind. Ich meine, wenn man sich große Politik anguckt, keine Ahnung, der jetzt ein aktuelles Beispiel, der Verfassungsschutzbericht.
Das ist halt auch wieder bei, wenn's um Internet geht, auch irgendwie wieder,
so, weiß ich nicht, wie viel Jahre zurück? So, ah, jetzt neue Rechte, an Taius Verlag und so, so come on, wenn du dich mit Rechtsextremismus aus so einem Netz beschäftigt hast, dann ist das so ein wahnsinnig alter Hut und ich gleichzeitig habe ich nicht das Gefühl, dass diese,
Potentiale von dem wie neue Rechte im Netz rekrutiert, komplett in allen Verfassungsschutzämtern und Ebenen dieses Dienstes verstanden werden immer. So und das ist natürlich ein Problem für uns als Gesellschaft.
Wobei beim Verfassungsschutz bin ich mir aber nicht so sicher, ob sie es nicht wissen oder ob sie nicht zugeben wollen.
Ja, dass es äh manchmal nicht so einfach zu sagen.
Ja. Okay, also du sagst im Prinzip, Journalismus hat hat äh hat aufgeholt. Das äh meine gut, beim Spiegel, im Spiegel muss man ja zu Gute halten,
wirklich ähm also mit Spiegel Online war ja Spiegel schon.
Echt weit vorne. Also da da haben sie ja zum richtigen Zeitpunkt äh Dinge nicht verhindert und das hat ihnen dann, glaube ich,
Riesenvorsprung gegeben. Hast du den Eindruck, dass sich das äh da redaktionell noch noch noch abbildet, dass das sozusagen, dass dass dieser Vorsprung in gewisser Hinsicht sich.
Noch zeigt, dass der mal da war.
Also ich bin erst zum Spiegel gekommen, nachdem die Fusionierung jetzt war, jetzt ist es ja irgendwie, also von Spiegel online und im Spiegel Verlag, jetzt ist es Spiegel DE. Ich finde, grade Netzthemen, ich.
Habe das Glück, da irgendwie in einer tollen Redaktion zu sein, ähm die Netzwelt halt, die halt genau diesen,
Fokus irgendwie hat, den ich auch spannend finde, so netzaffine Themen.
Für ein breites Publikum mit der ja mit mit politischer Berichterstattung zu verbinden und aufzubereiten sowohl irgendwie mal was Nerdiges zu machen als auch irgendwie so die großen.
Sich anzugucken, dass das finde ich schon super und das finde ich auch total wichtig, dass.
Das fände ich klasse, wenn jede größere Zeitung irgendwie wirklich ein gutes, digitales hätte und das auch investigativ auch arbeiten kann.
Finde ich schon wichtig.
Ja, wir hatten ja auch schon mal äh eine Kollegin von dir ähm bei uns, bei zweihundert. Also.
Genau zur Hälfte sozusagen die Judith äh horchert, die ja auch schon ähm da lange mitschreibt,
und ja, es äh eigentlich immer wieder auch gut zu sehen, dass der Spiegel durchaus äh in der Lage ist, Talent anzuwärmen. Insofern bist du äh perfekt
Perfekt eingestellt, um hier uns auch mal berichten zu können. Denn du hast ja einen.
Schwerpunkt ähm dir äh rausgearbeitet in den letzten Jahren, nämlich eben Telegram, haben wir ja schon erwähnt, da wollen wir heute mal so ein bisschen drüber äh quatschen. Ich glaube, mit dem Linus hat's du aber auch schon äh mehr Kontakt, ne?
Wir haben uns eigentlich, glaube ich, wenn ich das richtig erinnere, Max, du über Telegramm kennengelernt, das war wahrscheinlich.
Klingt jetzt falsch, Linus. Über das Feature Groups mir bei?
Über diese äh und zwar äh wir haben uns kennengelernt durch die old school Society auf Telegram, um es mal ganz hart zu sagen,
das das hatte ich auch glaube ich hier in Lokbuch Netzpolitik damals besprochen. Da war Max noch bei weiß und es ging da um.
Die die Art und Weise, wie die Polizei einen eine rechte Chatgruppe abgehört hat und die nannte sich.
Old School Society und der Gast ein Strafverfahren und die wurden irgendwie verboten oder so. Und da ging es, wenn ich das richtig erinnere, darum, dass.
Es eben in diesem Ermittlungsverfahren auftauchte, dass sie diesen Gruppenchat hatten und ähm wir haben nachvollzogen, wie sie es denn im Zweifelsfall angestellt haben. Habe ich das richtig in Erinnerung, Max?
Ja genau, also die Oldschool zur Zeit, die das war sozusagen nicht das, was man heute als rechte Chatgruppe meist bezeichnet so im Sinne von rechte Chatgruppe im Polizeibereich, sondern es ist
ganz kleine Gruppe gewesen, die von den äh Ermittlern der Staatsanwaltschaft als auch dann
entsprechenden Urteilen bestätigt als rechtsterroristische Gruppe. Die haben Anschläge geplant. Also die haben auf Telegram gechattet in im Sinne von.
Weiß ich nicht, man müsste mal Moscheen angreifen und so und ähm dann auch schon konkret über Tatmittel und dann haben die Ermittler zugegriffen.
Und ähm turns out, die hatten halt diese Chatnachrichten, die oder die tauchten dann irgendwie im im Ermittlungsverfahren auf und dann dachten die ähm dachte die Verteidigung
dass da ein SS sieben Angriff stattgefunden hätte,
und ähm das war eigentlich ursprünglich mein mein Zugang zum Thema und da da haben wir, glaube ich, damals auch drüber gesprochen, das wäre natürlich total krass. So, deutsche Polizei macht SS sieben auf eine Chatgruppe oder Bundeskriminalamt oder wer auch immer, ne?
Das war total unklar, es war beim Generalbundesanwalt aufgehangen, das Verfahren damals, also wegen Terror und so, also echt großes Verfahren.
Und das war aber nicht so, sondern die haben sozusagen dann viel einfacheren Trick gemacht. Die haben nämlich ein zweites Gerät angemeldet.
Auf dem Telegramm Account der Verdächtigen, die SMS konnten sie abfangen, weil sie eine richterliche Erlaubnis hatten zur Telekommunikationsüberwachung.
Und das ist ja ein Feature sozusagen, wenn du, weiß ich nicht, da auf deinem iPad oder auf deinem deinem äh was weiß ich, welchem welchem Pad die ähm.
Chats auch lesen willst von Telegram, dann kannst du ein zweites Gerät anmelden. Und so konnten sie halt mitlesen. Und das haben wir dann damals äh uns angeguckt und.
Nachvollzogen und ähm berichtet und das äh genau so so äh war das damals mit Old School Society, was ich immer noch irgendwie.
Lustigen Namen finde rechtsterroristische Gruppe, wenn ich so drüber nachdenke.
Und du bist dann irgendwie, also ich weiß, wir hatten immer mal wieder Austausch zu dem Thema, dann hast du mich irgendwann mal gefragt, hör mal, ey, dieses Telegramm da, der Typ, der Pavel, worauf oder wie der heißt. Kennst du den vielleicht?
Ich würd mal mit ihm sprechen und ja so kam es eigentlich dann auch zu dieser Sendung, dass also ich wusste immer so, wir haben ja auch in vielen anderen Themenbereichen irgendwie miteinander zu tun gehabt, aber ich wusste immer so, okay, Hopenstedt, der interessiert sich für Telegram. Und jetzt kam,
endlich würde ich sagen so deine große Spiegelstory zu dem Thema. Kann man schon so sagen, oder?
Ja, also ich finde Telegram einfach wirklich schon seitdem total spannend. Ich meine, das war damals noch so firmierte das oft in der Öffentlichkeit, so unter dem liebsten Messenger des sogenannten Islamischen Staats.
Ähm und der Krypto-Messenger Telegram und so und das waren ja damals schon so ein paar Missverständnisse. Da werden wir bestimmt auch nochmal drüber reden, aber,
Es stimmt natürlich, dass Chats dort Ende zu verendet verschlüsselt sein können, auch tatsächlich vor WhatsApp hatten sie das Feature schon, dass man Ende zu Ende verschlüsselt chatten kann. Ähm.
Kann man sagen, NSN-Verschlüsselung vor WhatsApp schon sozusagen zu gebracht.
Aber es ist nie standardmäßig Ende zu Ende verschlüsselt, was eben den Ermittlern auch geholfen hat, da äh mitzulesen auf dem zweiten Gerät und das wussten ganz viele Leute nicht. Und so gibt's also total viele Missverständnisse dadrum und gleichzeitig halt so
wer steckt dahinter genau und damals gab es irgendwie immer mal wieder so Berichte und Andeutungen und das.
Die dann auch selber später bestätigt, dass die teilweise in Berlin waren und und irgendwie das Entwickler teilweise hier in Berlin saßen, da hatte ich noch so die naive Vorstellung, okay, keine Ahnung, die
muss doch irgendjemand kennen, wenn die hier in Berlin sitzen und einer der weltgrößten Messenger, so, da wird dort doch irgendjemand über Ecken, die kennen und ich glaube, das waren total viele Journalisten irgendwie,
versucht, was hinter diesem Briefkasten rauszukriegen, der den's hier in Berlin gegeben haben soll. Hat natürlich nicht geklappt, aber seitdem interessiere ich mich halt irgendwie total für dieses Unternehmen und es ist ja.
Massivst gewachsen. Das ist ja jetzt gar nicht mehr so der liebste Messenger des IS. Jetzt ist es vielleicht der liebste Messenger, der der Querdenker, glaubt man so in der Öffentlichkeit. Gleichzeitig ist so die liebste Ausweichplattform von von WhatsApp, ne, nachdem,
jetzt Anfang des Jahres halt diese neuen WhatsApp-Nutzungsbedingungen gab und Leute plötzlich gemerkt haben, dass der Datenschutz auf WhatsApp vielleicht doch nicht so gut ist, wie sie immer dachten. Und dann irgendwie zu anderen Messengern wechseln wollten.
Hatte Telegram da echt mehr Zuwachs als Signal?
Telegram hat mehr neue Nutzer gewonnen, die haben äh alleine im Januar mehr als ähm.
Ich müsste die genaue Zahl nachgucken, aber ich glaube, also mehrere Millionen. Ich glaube, fünfundzwanzig Millionen haben sie gesagt, an neuen Nutzerinnen und Nutzern bekommen. Das war auf jeden Fall deutlich mehr als Signal.
Global jetzt, ne? Man man kann natürlich immer nicht sagen, ob diese fünfundzwanzig Millionen, wenn die Zahl jetzt stimmt, nagelt mich nicht drauf fest, aber es ist auf jeden Fall in diesem Bereich, ähm wenn wenn diese.
Dass die alle WhatsApp deinstalliert haben. Das kann man jetzt natürlich nicht sagen, aber es gab total viele Neuinstallationen. Also wenn man Telegram selber hatte, kam da irgendwie so im
Minuten Takt oder weiß nicht, auf deinem, du hast ja letztes Mal erzählt, Linus irgendwie deinen Burner vorne, hast du auch Telefon, was wahrscheinlich deine Kontakte synchronisiert, hoffe ich, aber ähm.
Wenn du das gemacht hättest, dann hättest du da im Minutentakt oder oder ja alle Viertelstunde gesehen, der ist auch auf Telegram, der ist auch auf Telegram, die ist auf Telegramm, die ist auf Telegramm. Das ist natürlich schon ähm ja irgendwie komisch, auch sozusagen so.
Journalisten prominente Personen, bekannte Personen, ähm haben dann Telegram sich äh auch geholt, weil sie irgendwie ähm ja das.
Für eine gute Idee hielten oder eine spannende Plattform. Was es vielleicht auch ist so, das das hat auch total viele Vorteile das muss man auch sagen, ähm aber genau.
Bevor wir vielleicht mal so auf das äh was auf Telegramm eigentlich so geht ähm kommen
Du hast ja primär in deiner Story ein bisschen so zu dem Hintergrund und dann speziell eben auch auf diese Gründungsfigur da hin äh recherchiert, was
wie bist du da ran gegangen? Was hast du denn da bei heraus bekommen? Was was so dein Eindruck, was ist das für ein Unternehmen?
Also ähm man muss noch dazu sagen oder das ist wichtig dazu zu sagen, dass dass ich das nicht alleine gemacht habe, das hätte ich auch niemals geschafft, sondern wir haben das sozusagen mit einem mit einem Team, beim, beim Spiegel gemacht und ähm Pavel Durov stammt ursprünglich aus aus Russland,
ist jetzt zumindest laut seines Instagram-Accounts und irgendwie anderen Hinweisen immer mal wieder in in Dubai.
Die Firma hat da auch einen offiziellen Firmensitz zumindest und die Kollegin Christina Hebel, die ähm Russlandkorrespondentin vom Spiegel war, mit im Team und Marcel Rosenbach, auch der
sich auch mit äh Technikthemen irgendwie sehr gut ausgeht und auskennt und zu dritt haben wir uns das Thema irgendwie angeguckt und äh Christina hat dann zum Beispiel einfach im im Umfeld der Firma recherchiert. Wir haben natürlich,
ganz am Anfang vor allen Dingen die immer wieder kontaktiert. Ich meine, das habe ich schon seit Jahren oder.
Die die anderen beiden auch immer wieder gemacht und dieser Pavel Duroff ist einfach eine wahnsinnig spannende Figur, ist eine eine irre Geschichte.
Und äh auch sehr, sozusagen ähm ja äußert sich gerne.
Prägnant und pointiert öffentlich nicht mehr gegenüber Journalisten, sondern irgendwie über seinen eigenen Blog oder über Instagram, aber früher auch auf Konferenzen und sagt dann halt so Sachen wie WhatsApp, Sax,
So, also er macht richtig Ansagen. Ähm natürlich im eigenen Sinne, um seinen eigenen Dienst zu bewerben, aber hat auch irgendwie äh sehr prägnante Meinungen auch gegen.
Zum Beispiel Zensurbemühungen und ähm schaut sich das an und das ist einfach eine total spannende äh Figur und.
Aber halt versucht den zu kontaktieren. Ja, das ist nicht so richtig was geworden ähm oder was heißt nicht so richtig, wir haben es wurde einfach nicht geantwortet.
Kannst du dir nicht einfach über Telegram kontaktieren.
Natürlich, das haben wir natürlich auch gemacht, äh Mails schreiben, Chatnachrichten schreiben, ähm aber es kommt einfach keine Antwort. Von niemandem aus der Firma.
Der Duo, ich meine, der ist ja nicht mit Telegramm gestartet, sondern der hat ja äh schon dieses V-Kontakte äh in Russland gestartet, was so ein bisschen als,
Kann man, glaube ich, so als Facebook-Equivalent, glaube ich, äh locker beschreiben, nicht, dass ich das jemals äh benutzt hätte, aber.
In der Zeit war er schon äh aktiv und hat da eben dazu beigetragen. Und ich denke, diese russischen äh Netze stehen ja auch immer so ein bisschen in dem Ruf oder sagen wir mal.
Würde mal uns unterstellen, dass wir so ein bisschen die Sicht darauf haben. Na ja, wenn du jetzt Unternehmer in Russland bist, dann, und das haben wir ja im, im, im
in dem in dem wirtschaftlichen Bereich, wo es so um physikalische Güter geht, so Energie und ne, also das ganze Big Business haben wir ja gesehen, wie wie Putin und seine äh Schergen in den letzten Jahrzehnten diese ganze Wirtschaft, die ja
in den neunziger Jahren so drohte, so ein Staat im Staat zu werden, ganz gut eingeordnet bekommen. Scheint aber jetzt so, dass äh zumindest im Falle von Pavel Duro und im digitalen Space.
Gar nicht so einfach zu sein scheint.
Total früh ähm erkannt Pavel Dorow zusammen mit seinem Bruder Nikolai Durov, der ein paar Jahre älter ist und auch so der Techniker dahinter ist, der ist noch viel weniger in der Öffentlichkeit oder oder tritt sozusagen gar nicht in der Öffentlichkeit in Entscheidung, ist aber auch.
Spannend und diesen Schein ein kongeniales Duo zu sein und haben eben beide total früh erkannt, äh was.
Mit äh Social Media möglich sein wird. Also manche bezeichnen V-Kontakte auch. Du hast es jetzt ein Facebook-Equivalent genannt, manche sagen auch weniger, es schmeichelhaft einen Facebook
Klon, äh während äh in Petersburg studiert hat, äh Pavel Dorf an der Uni hat er eben einfach so eine, eigentlich sozusagen so ähnlich, deswegen ist dieser Mark Zuckerbauvergleich wirklich passend.
Ähnlich wie Mark Zuckerberg hat der so eine Universitätsweite Plattform ähm aufgebaut, auf der man oder zwei verschiedene, auf der man sozusagen miteinander schreiben konnte und sich austauschen konnte und so weiter und er hat total früh erkannt,
was das für ein Potential äh hat und was für ein Bedarf danach eigentlich besteht. Und das, was du jetzt gerade beschrieben hast, das das ist halt,
Geschichte so spannend, weil er ähm äh Pawel Durov sich öffentlich immer wieder sehr prägnant ähm gegen.
Anordnung des russischen Staates gewehrt hat. Also es gibt zum Beispiel,
den Fall ähm bei äh ähm V-Kontakte, dass äh bestimmte Gruppen mh Navalni beziehungsweise nicht nur Navali Protestgruppen ähm.
Da gesperrt werden sollten,
V-Kontakte, was damals schon mehrere Millionen Nutzer hatte, also wirklich nur große, wichtige Mobilisierungsplattformen auch war, über die eben zu Protesten aufgerufen wurde in Russland.
Und äh hat das nicht gemacht,
und hat halt stattdessen äh sozusagen die Anordnung, die an ihn ging vom äh FSB, vom russischen Inlandsgeheimdienst gepostet, öffentlich auf Twitter zusammen mit einem Foto eines Hundes im Hoodie, der die Zunge rausstreckt.
Paar Tage später stehen halt äh steht die äh Sondereinheit äh OMO bei dem bei ihm vor der äh Tür oder beziehungsweise,
in seiner Wohnung auf dem Petersburger Prachtboulevard da war das schon ein schillernder Start-up-Unternehmer, wie man vielleicht sagen würde
ähm auf Boulevard in in Petersburg. So und wollen halt die Wohnung stürmen. Und das hat sich später nochmal wiederholt. Der äh hat sich immer wieder gegen.
Ähm Zensur und gegen Zugriff vom Staat, vom russischen Staat am Anfang äh gewehrt öffentlich
manche sagen halt, das ist nicht so sehr politische Positionierung, sondern wirtschaftliches Kalkül auch, das bringt sozusagen auch einfach Nutzer und hat die.
Sicherlich da auch genutzt, dass das stimmt, aber.
Es wäre auch falsch zu sagen, dass er nicht sozusagen auf bestimmte politische libertäre Ansichten hat er geäußert, äh hegt, die eben so ganz klar Antizensur sind.
Von daher
Ja, es gibt auch Berichte, dass es immer mal wieder irgendwie äh Anbahnungsversuche bei verschiedenen Mitarbeiterinnen und Mitarbeitern von Telegram gegeben haben soll, durch den russischen Geheimdienst. Worauf selbst hat später gesagt, der FBI hätte ihnen
ähm äh angesprochen, man hätte allem immer äh sozusagen widerstanden und alles zurückgewiesen und so, das sind so sehr diffuse Berichte, also.
Das kann ich natürlich nicht abschließend sagen, aber.
Die jetzt völlig, wie, weiß ich nicht, ein russischer Staatskonzern äh oder irgendein staatsnaher Ölkonzern in der Tasche des Kremls sind, das kann man sicherlich ausschließen.
Also man muss ja noch dazu sagen, diese V-Kontaktegeschichte mit Nawalnis-Seite und äh der wollte, wollte die,
wollten sie auch Daten von ukrainischen ähm
das haben, also von Demonstranten und er hat diese Dinger, diese Dinger gepostet und ist sehr kurz darauf, als äh CEO von äh VK auch äh
worden, ne? Und hat dann zwanzig vierzehn äh russland verlassen mit den mit dem Satz, er hätte keine Pläne zurückzugehen und
das Land sei inkompatibel äh mit Internet-Business, also da da hat er schon äh.
Eine derartige ähm Entschlossenheit würde man jetzt bei Mark Zuckerberg oder Tim guckt doch ähm äh suchen, ne, dass sie,
sich äh von ihrem eigenen äh aus aus ihrem eigenen Unternehmen als CEO kicken lassen und das Land verlassen, das ist schon ähm na ja, er fordert ähm.
Wahrscheinlich durchaus auch Berücksichtigung und Anerkennung. Gleichzeitig ist der Typ halt ein Milliardär, der kann also für den ist Umziehen nicht so nicht so teuer, ne?
Ja, als Umzugsunternehmen ist äh bezahlbar auf jeden Fall. Ja, absolut, also diese diese Geschichte da mit dem mit dem Hund im Hoodie und der Zunge raus, ist äh zwei dreizehn. Das ist.
Damals die, die bis dahin landesweit größte Protestwelle ähm in Russland gewesen und das war so ein bisschen der, der Auftakt deines öffentlichen Scharmützels und das, was du,
beschrieben hast, Linus ist dann halt ein Jahr später, genau, da geht's auch um Maidern, Euromeidern, Proteste, äh ukrainische Oppositionsgruppen,
und ähm darauf hatte das Kapital ähm sondern auch von Investoren und da hat sich die Struktur ein bisschen gewandelt, da hatten kremelnnahe Investor,
ohne dass Pavadoro auf das auch wusste oder dem oder zumindest zugestimmt hätte mehr Anteile gewonnen und so wurde er sozusagen aus dem,
durfte, aber im Gegenzug, was er schon angefangen hat, während dieser Scharmützelzeit zu programmieren, Telegramm behalten, sozusagen, das erzählt man.
Der der Deal gewesen ist und und Telegram ist natürlich heute viel relevanter, als VK, was halt mal wieder zeigt.
Dass die Telekom ist dadurch virales irgendwie viral gewachsen. Ja, die haben nie Werbekampagne also geschaltet, muss man auch mal sagen.
Und natürlich haben die nicht die gleiche Strahlkraft wie das Silicon Valley natürlicherweise, dass man sagt, okay, welche App installiere ich mir? Ja okay, WhatsApp, das ist die, die aus den USA und so weiter. Trotzdem haben die das geschafft, einen riesen Messenger aufzubauen und das liegt halt schon auch an ihren.
An ihren technischen Fähigkeiten und schon auch ähm an der Bedeutung zum Beispiel für,
Bürgerrechtsbewegungen in repressiven Ländern, die sich äh da eben Telegramm ausgesucht haben, das muss man schon, glaube ich, äh so konstatieren.
Dann lass uns doch mal die äh Ist-Situation auf Telegramm jetzt mal beleuchten. Also,
bin jetzt nicht so ein Heavy-User von Telegramm irgendwann mal einen Account gemacht lustigerweise, als ich äh für ein paar Tage mal in Hong Kong war, einfach weil ne dann man sofort ähm
mitbekommen, dass äh andere Länder, andere Sitten, andere Kommunikationsstandards, äh Telegramm da einfach eine große Bedeutung hat. Ich meine, ich habe mich da jetzt nicht groß in die Bürgerrechtsbewegung eingeklinkt, so,
aber äh es war dann sozusagen interessant zu sehen so, okay, passiert jetzt hier gerade eigentlich was, das war so kurz bevor es so richtig schlimm wurde.
Und alle nur so, ja, Telegramm, Telegramm, Telegram, das ist hier irgendwie so der der Kommunikationsweg und da merkt man schon so, aha, okay, alles klar. Da äh läuft so ein bisschen was anders,
Was ist so deine Wahrnehmung? Wofür sich Telegramm so als Tummel und Kommunikationsplatz etabliert hat.
Also.
Wie natürlich jede Tech-Plattform nimmt, muss man sagen, kommt sozusagen drauf an, wie man's benutzt. Ich benutze Telegram halt für Recherchen, ich benutze es nicht zur privaten Kommunikation. Ähm auch wenn's immer mal wieder Bekannte gibt,
die sagen ähm bist du eigentlich auf Telegram, dann äh sage ich eher nein, lass uns lieber irgendwie einen anderen Messenger benutzen.
Aber ähm das ist sozusagen einfach meine persönliche Präferenz, aber wenn man's als Recherche-Tool benutzt, so wie ich oder wir das gemacht haben im Team, dann ist das schon.
Ziemlich verrückt, weil ihr müsst euch das so vorstellen, ja? Man abonniert halt Kanäle und Gruppen, die sind eigentlich das Bedeutendste Feature,
ähm würde ich sagen, für die politische Debatte, die wir jetzt um Telegramm führen, also es sind öffentliche Kanäle und Gruppen. Und da kannst du halt ähm die
in Deutschland bekannten Kanälen und Gruppen, wie hielt man abonnieren, du kannst aber auch Gruppen abonnieren, in denen ähm lokale Gruppen, in denen,
Drogen äh angeboten werden und verkauft werden, wie so eine Art Drogenlieferando. Ähm gefälschte Impfausweise, Kuanon und du musst dir das halt dann so vorstellen, dann dann hast du irgendwie die,
Telegramm auf deinem Handy und wenn du die Benachrichtigung aktiviert hättest, was ich nicht getan habe, weil das würde mich verrückt machen, dann dann kommt einfach so
Impfausweis, Kölner Stempel, Biontek, weiß ich nicht, fünfzig Euro, nächste Nachricht,
suche Drogen, bauen Schulen weg, Zehner Ende des Monats kann jemand guten Preis machen, nächste Nachricht irgendwie,
anderen Leute seid ihr erleuchtet vom Licht weiß ich nicht hier ist der neue wird uns doch noch alle retten. Nächste Nachricht irgendwie.
Terror, Nazi, Verherrlichungs Hitler reden und so weiter und so fort. Ja oder oder auch sozusagen die die guten Seiten ähm irgendwie der Kampf der der russischen Opposition, der halt maßgeblich darüber,
ähm ja organisiert angetrieben wurde. Das war sozusagen der erste Ort, wo ähm auf großer Basis äh,
Bilder der Gewalt, der bei der russischen Sicherheitskräfte geteilt wurden
und das hat eben zu dieser Empörung überhaupt geführt, die die Proteste nochmal viel größer gemacht hat. Also das ist kann schon sehr verrückt sein, was du da in deinem Feed sozusagen kriegst, wenn du da auf Telegram das eben in der Art und Weise benutzt, ähm.
Ja, wir haben's halt beschrieben, so als Darknet für die Hosentasche. Weißt du, alles ungefiltert in den krassesten Sachen, die du dir vorstellen kannst. Ähm so ist es irgendwie.
Also wie Darknetig, das ist es wird nachher nochmal drüber sprechen. Ich habe jetzt tatsächlich mal äh eine Frage. Ich habe ja auch, also meine Recherche, Telefon, bei dem ich die Kontakte nicht freigegeben habe und das nicht auf meine richtige Nummer äh registriert ist.
Und ähm ich habe da auch mal äh versehentlich,
mich umgeschaut in so einer Drogengruppe, ja? Ähm und habe da genau das mal beobachtet, weil mir äh tatsächlich, weil mehrere Hörerinnen mich hier angeschrieben haben, sagten so, ja hier Linus, ne, äh sag mal,
Drogen kaufen auf Telegramm oder Nay und einige waren auch dabei, die gefragt haben, Drogen verkaufen auf Telegram oder nicht.
Die haben beide äh den gleichlautenden Rat von mir bekommen. Ähm.
Also das äh vielleicht kurz äh,
erwähnt zu haben. Das ist natürlich jedes Mal ein Problem, wenn du irgendeine fremde Person, die in irgendeiner Telegram-Gruppe gesagt hat, ich äh kaufe oder ich verkaufe Drogen triffst, dann hilft dir natürlich auch dieser Messenger nicht mehr,
ähm wobei ich höre auch, äh das kann ich allerdings äh nicht sagen, dass das habe ich nicht selber,
dass sie äh professionelle Telegram-Dealer auch darauf achten, dass sie dann keinen persönlichen Kontakt haben.
Sondern dich irgendwo äh hinschicken, wo wo die Drogen vorher positioniert wurden ähm und hier einfach nur noch das Versteck genannt wird oder so. Das habe ich aber,
da habe ich keine Ahnung. Äh ich weiß aus meinen dem, was ich gehört habe, weiß ich nur, dass auch viele nicht machen. Ähm.
Da hilft dir natürlich auch dieser Messenger nicht mehr. Aber was mir da aufgefallen ist
ich guck da ja auch nicht so oft rein und jetzt gestern in Vorbereitung der Sendung hab ich's dann mal wieder getan und jetzt bin ich auf einmal in
zwanzig Drogengruppen. Ähm ich habe da nicht gesagt, ich möchte da rein. Also ist das irgendwie der Netzwerkeffekt, der da stattfindet, dass die alle immer irgendwie die Gruppen klonen oder wie funktioniert ja die also wie funktioniert das
oder warum funktioniert das, dass man da alles so schnell findet und trotzdem in so ein gesogen wird wie bei Facebook, obwohl man ja,
davon ausgehen würde und auch den Eindruck hat, dass das immer irgendwie so Schätz und Gruppen sind, wo man vielleicht nicht so einfach reinkäme.
Also man muss vielleicht nochmal sagen, es gibt ähm öffentliche und nicht-öffentliche Gruppen.
Bei den Drogenhandel gibt's auch beides und dann gibt es Kanäle, Kanäle, da kann sozusagen ein Administrator oder Administratorin oder auch ein Team,
sozusagen seine, ihre Nachrichten äh an eine unbegrenzte Anzahl an Empfängerinnen und Empfänger senden,
In den Gruppen können es ähm mehrere hunderttausend äh Nutzerinnen und Nutzer sein, also die können sozusagen potentiell riesig sein,
und ja es ist schon so bisschen wie du sagst, so kennst du also kennst du eine, kennst du alle so ungefähr, ähm wenn du halt so in so einer Drogengruppe bist, dann ähm
fügen diese Gruppen, die Betreiber dieser Gruppen dich anderen Gruppen hinzu. Ähm und es gibt für jede größere deutsche Stadt diese,
Drogenverkaufsgruppen, in denen sozusagen mit buntesten Emojis alle möglichen Drogen angeboten werden, also mit mit Videos und hier die neue, tolle Lieferung und.
Habe ich auch gesehen.
Ja gibst sozusagen das ganze Programm, was du machen kannst, um im Netz Dinge anzupreisen, so Kokain aus Peru zweiundneunzig Prozent, an so sieben Schneeemojis dazu. Ähm,
das ist halt ähm.
Irgendwie einerseits lustig, andererseits halt schon auch krass, wenn du dir anguckst, welche Art von Drogen da angeboten werden, also Fetanühl wird auch angeboten und und,
diverse andere so echt harte Sachen und halt auch
sowohl klein als auch im großen Stil, also so diese diese Nachricht hier, weiß nicht, kann jemand ein Gramm für einen Zehner äh Baumschwimmweg klarmachen? Ist wieder Monatsende so, das ist natürlich irgendwie so ein kleinerer Rahmen,
aber es gibt auch ähm Drogen im großen Stil, die da verkauft werden und es ist halt ähm ja, die ganze Palette des,
Drogenhandels, weswegen sich ähm oder vielleicht nicht die ganz, ganz große Palette. Ähm da gibt's dann natürlich die Krypto-Phones, die irgendwie die Kartelle benutzen und so, aber sozusagen bis dahin, was sozusagen den den,
Also es gibt eine Ermittlungsgruppe EG Messenger heißt die in Berlin vom Landeskriminalamt extra dafür ähm zu zu Drogen auf Telegramm.
Und die sagen, dass äh auch Großdialer in diesen Gruppen verkaufen, also sozusagen äh Leute kaufen dort äh Drogen im größeren Stil und verkaufen sie dann ähm weiter. Also es sind verschiedene Ebenen. Es gibt auch,
Hinweise, dass die organisierte Kriminalität da ähm mit drin hängen soll, sagen irgendwie Ermittler und es ist halt einfach auch so.
Ja, dass dass einerseits echt erschreckend ist, wie einfach das da gemacht wird, andererseits genau, was du gesagt hast, Linus,
es ist immer ein Problem, wenn du dich halt äh danach als Dealer mit deinen Kunden dann doch irgendwie treffen musst. Ähm da hat dann die Polizei Zukunftsmöglichkeiten. Genau das ist zum Beispiel in in Frankfurt ähm,
Ermittlern gelungen, von der Generalstaatsanwaltschaft da und äh ja auch hier in in Berlin gibt's irgendwie Verfahren im mittleren zweistelligen Bereich. Inzwischen sagen die, also,
Aber nochmal zu der organisiert hat, das ist tatsächlich mit mehreren Ebenen organisiert. Also eine Gruppe soll sogar aus Kuba administriert worden sein und
der oder die Person, die dann dahintersteckt, äh hat dann halt in Berlin wieder welche, die irgendwie
die einzelnen Accounts machen, vielleicht auch für einzelne Drogen nur verantwortlich sind, die haben dann wieder Leute, die fahren. Also das ist schon ähm ja, eine,
komplexere Organisation scheint das zu sein da.
Frage mich tatsächlich also so, aber so schlau scheinen die wirklich nicht zu sein, weil ich habe in keiner Telegram-Gruppe jemals irgendetwas gepostet
Ich bin dann reiner und.
Also das wäre das wäre der erste, den ich raus äh kicken würde, ne? Irgend so ein der sich das ganze Spektakel da einfach nur anschaut. Und ähm,
sowohl in irgendwelchen Nazigruppen als auch in irgendwelchen Querdenkergruppen als auch in irgendwelchen Drogengruppen werde ich da bereitwillig ähm mitgeführt.
Ja? Erschienen erschien mir jetzt auf Anhieb äh hätte ich gedacht, dass die Leute äh sich ein bisschen mehr Mühe geben, aber äh ja gleichzeitig haben sie natürlich auch vorne rein Mitleserinnen nicht wirklich was zu befürchten, denn man muss ja auch sagen, bei diesen Gruppen ist es ja so, in der Gruppe wird ja nur der Bedarf
äh announced.
Und die Antwort kommt dann, glaube ich, in der äh äh Privatnachricht, wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe. Oder den Antwort nie jemand in der Gruppe könnte auch sein.
Ja, genau, es ist mir bestimmt beides möglich. Die sagen dann immer, okay, äh Secret Chat, also das ist die Ende zu Ende. Ähm,
auf Telegram gibt, die man speziell aktivieren muss, um Kontakt aufzunehmen und um dann sozusagen den Deal über die Bühne zu bringen, das ist das, was da immer.
Wird, ähm aber ich würde das auch unterschreiben, also das das Unrechtsbewusstsein der Leute auf Telegram,
scheint wirklich sehr gering zu sein und das gilt jetzt halt nicht nur für Drogen, ähm sondern es gilt halt auch für Terror. Also es gibt dieses sogenannte Terrogramm Szene, Terrogramm, ähm das ist so ein Beinahme, den Telegram sich eingefangen hat äh für
einfach wirklich Terrorverherrlichende Gruppen,
in denen es wie das hat jetzt nicht mehr in unseren Artikel es geschafft, aber der Merodittrich, das ist so ein, ja, von der Online-Monitoring-Organisation CEMA ist einfach wirklich ein absoluter Experte für für Telegram, der sich das auch seit,
seit Jahren intensivst anguckt, also Rechtsextremismus und extremistische Gruppen auf Telegramm und der sagt halt, das geht dazu.
In dieser Terrogrammszene wie in den schlimmsten Zeiten von
vor und nach dem Amoklauf von Christchurch. Also da gibt's halt Leute, die posten die Manifeste, die nennen sich wie der Attentäter von Christchurch, die verherrlichen den in einer Tour
ähm und da passieren dann auch tatsächlich Straftaten, also Verbreitung, verfassungsfeindlicher Kennzeichen und auch einfach, also es gibt auch so, es gibt die absurdesten Sachen, es gibt so SS-Art,
in Anführungsstrichen Gruppen, also so wo dann so so fotoshop Kunst gemacht wird mit mit Nazisymbolik,
und auch einfach das Verbreiten von von Reden aus der nationalsozialistischen Zeit und so diversen anderen Sachen und in dieser Terrorszene, da gibt's auch teilweise dann Sprengstoff.
Bau, Anleitung und so und die.
Das Motto da ist halt, wer ist no Political Solution, so hießen Kanal, der inzwischen geschlossen wurde. Also, es gibt keine politische Lösung mehr
die Lösung ist, ist Terror. Die Lösung ist Amoklauf, das ist das, was verherrlicht wird. Natürlich heißt das nicht, dass jeder, der da mitliest und diese Gruppen sei jetzt nicht tausende, ähm, es gibt welche, die haben mehr als tausend Mitglieder. Die haben irgendwie dreihundert, öffentlich alles, ne?
Ähm.
Muss nicht aufgenommen werden. Ähm das heißt natürlich nicht, dass selbst von diesen hunderten dann jeder zur Waffe greift, so, aber es ähm gab auch einen verhinderten äh Amoklauf in in Texas, laut Ermittlungen vor einigen Wochen,
und der wurde halt auch sofort wieder verherrlicht in diesen Gruppen und der der Täter hat äh soll wohl hinter einer Telegram-Gruppe stecken oder hat Verbindung hinter einer entsprechenden Terror Telegram.
Gruppe so, also das ist schon sehr, sehr krass teilweise.
Jetzt haben wir eine ganze Menge ja rechtlich zu beanstanden. Der Inhalte da festgestellt. Und in der letzten Sendung habe ich ja.
Spekuliert, äh dass äh Attila Hildmanns Telegram-Kanal irgendwie oft betreiben von Google und Apple ähm,
vielleicht dort seine Reichweite auf diesen Geräten verloren hätte. Ähm und habe gesagt, dass es mir eigentlich nicht anders erklären kann. Wenn du jetzt erzählst, es gibt diese ganzen krassen Inhalte, ähm.
Dann scheint meine Thesia etwas zu leiden, oder?
Also.
Problem ist, dass man nicht besonders viel darüber weiß, wie gut oder schlecht Telegramm Inhalte moderiert, ne? Nach dem Sturm aufs Capitol, hatten Sprecher vom Unternehmen sinngemäß gesagt, äh Telegram ist no Place for.
Weil eben auch diese Gruppen, diese US-Miliz sich dort auch organisiert haben, Leute aus dieser Terrorszene dort gechattet haben und nach dem Sturm aufs Capitol das auch äh als also sozusagen als Ausweichplattform,
beworben wurde, also Facebook, Twitter, YouTube sind stärker vorgegangen gegen rechtsextremistische Gruppen.
Der Hauptausweich-Ort oder einer der zentralen Ausweichauto war immer Telegramm. Und Telegram hat dann tatsächlich auch ein bisschen was gelöscht.
Ähm das das muss man sagen äh aber bei weitem nicht alles. Äh man findet immer noch rechtsterroristische Gruppen, dann teilweise halt die Gruppe zwei, so wie Attila Hildmaier jetzt eben auch irgendwie eine Ausweich.
Auf Telegram bewirbt. Ähm und,
Es gibt eine Studie von der Organisation Jugendschutz Net, die führen öfters so Tests durch. Die haben ähm letzten Sommer äh ist die veröffentlicht worden und die haben festgestellt, dass nur in elf, die haben sozusagen Inhalte gemeldet, ne. Die Art von Inhalte, über die.
Grade gesprochen habe oder dass das äh Terrorvideo vom Täter von Halle ist, da war Telegram eine wichtige äh Scharnierfunktion, wo das eine größere Reichweite bekommen hat. Das war erst irgendwie so auf Twitch und haben da irgendwie.
Vier Leute oder ganz wenige nur gesehen. Hm, Telegram war dann die Plattform, wo's in die zehntausenden äh von ähm Aufrufzahlen kam,
und das ist ganz lange an genau dem selben Ort, in einem relativ bekannten Kanal, dieser dieser Terroran-Szene, den sozusagen jeder Experte kennt, der sich das anguckt.
Ähm äh stand das einfach immer noch drin, also was bedeutet es war auf den Servern von Telegram ähm und.
Die haben sich angeguckt, wenn wir solche Sachen melden, wie viel verschwindet dann? Elf Prozent der Inhalte verschwinden. Die anderen bleiben stehen.
Sie also sozusagen klar rechtsextremistische Inhalte, aber man weiß eben nicht viel darüber, wie viel Telegramm löscht. Ich meine, ich kann jetzt beschreiben, was ich offenkundig sehe. Du Linus hast ja auch schon noch irgendwie Hacking-Gruppen erzählt, wenn ich's richtig verstehe, dass eher nicht so,
Sachen, aber es gibt natürlich auch Gruppen, in denen irgendwie gehackte Daten angeboten werden, gefälschte Impfausweisen, so, man kann das alles sehen und es scheint nicht so zu sein,
als würde dort besonders restriktiv gelöscht.
Aber wir wissen eben einfach nichts darüber. Wenn wir uns darüber beschweren, dass man das irgendwie Facebook ein intransparentes Unternehmen ist oder Twitter, wenn es darum geht,
Trump gesperrt, wird Trump nicht gesperrt auf welcher Grundlage er wird diese Entscheidung getroffen, also,
weiß ich nicht, was die Steigerung davon ist bei Telegram, sowas, was die intransparenz dessen angeht, wie dort Moderation stattfindet. Und das ist halt.
Das Problem und das sieht man auch bei der Hildmann Sache wieder. Ähm Telegram hat uns nicht geantwortet auf die Frage und hat auch sich öffentlich nicht dazu geäußert.
Ob man selbst für diese Sperrung auf iOS und Android-Geräten verantwortlich ist. Äh Apple und Google haben dementiert. Dafür.
Direkt verantwortlich zu.
Das wiederum heißt nicht, dass es nicht auch Gespräche geben könnte zwischen Apple und Google. Denn das eine für Telegram ist natürlich nicht auf Anordnung von Behörden zu reagieren, was sie sozusagen,
ähm ja, relativ äh also sie sagen unverhohlen öffentlich, dass sie's,
schwer machen und sehr hohe Hürden anlegen. Deutsche Behörden sagen, sie sind eine überhaupt nicht zu erreichen
das ist das eine, das du für Behörden und Staaten nicht erreichbar bist offenkundig. Das andere ist äh oder nur schwer erreichbar, dass du für Apple und Google nicht erreichbar bist. Das kannst du dir eigentlich nicht leisten als große App, ja?
Und deswegen ist eine andere Vermutung zu zu dem, was du letztes Mal spekuliert hast, dass ähm sozusagen Apple und Google ähm dahinterstecken könnten,
Ist halt das Telegramm einfach proaktiv reagiert, um zu zeigen.
Ähm um sozusagen so einen Faller zu verhindern. Parla ist ja die App, die gelöscht wurde nach dem Sturm aufs Capitol, aus dem App Store mit der Begründung von Apple,
Tim hat das in dem Interview auch irgendwie bei FOX News auch in die entsprechende Zielgruppe so klar kommuniziert,
wenn wir sehen, dass dort keine Moderation stattfindet, keine Art von Moderation offensichtlich oder von von systematischer und struktureller Moderation, dann schreiten wir ein,
und deswegen wäre eine andere Leser, dass ähm Telegramm die die Möglichkeit haben sie offensichtlich, das haben sie auch schon in der Vergangenheit bei anderen Sachen getan, die Gruppen für Apple und Googles sperrt.
Um den zu zeigen, sozusagen.
Im Sinne eurer App-Store Regeln machen wir eine bestimmte Art von Moderation. Man kann jetzt darüber diskutieren, wie konsistent und strukturell äh die ist sozusagen, aber wir wir machen das und ansonsten und das würde auch dazu passen, dass sie sich selbst als.
Ort der der Meinungsfreiheit und Antizensur gerieren in unseren eigenen Apps.
Sind die Kanäle weiterhin verfügbar. Äh also sozusagen in den Telegram-Apps, äh in der Rap-Version von Telegram.
Und in dem äh Desktop-Programm ist der Tele ist der Kanal ja weiterhin verfügbar. Das wäre eine andere Lea davon. Aber wir wissen's am Ende sozusagen schlicht nicht.
Also ich muss gerade echt nur um, weil es ist sorry, ich muss das kurz hier zitieren. Hier ist einer, ich gucke hier gerade in so eine Gruppe, ja.
Hier ist äh einer mit, mit einem, also hat einen anonym also nicht seine Telefonnummer da erkennbar, hat aber als
Account bilden Selfie erkennbar ein Selfie von sich selber und schreibt in so einer Gruppe die Nachricht, tauscht wer ein Gramm gegen ein Monat Spotify.
Und das erinnert mich einfach an diesen alten Witz, ne? Was sagt ein Kiffer zum anderen, wenn das Gras alle ist?
Mach mal die scheiß Mucke aus. Und deswegen verstehe ich, warum der sein Spotify loswerden möchte. Finde ich auf jeden Fall sehr schön. Ich hätt's nicht mit Selfie gepostet, aber äh das das scheint dann eher so diese kleine,
Kriminalität zu sein, die da äh stattfindet, ne?
Ja, wobei das, was du sozusagen vorhin ähm beschrieben hast, äh dass da offensichtlich irgendwie kein Unrechtsbewusstsein herrscht oder man halt einfach da glaubt, alles machen zu können.
Rührt halt auch daher das Telegramm halt, also die sagen in ihren ähm wir haben bis heute null Nutzerdaten an Behörden weitergegeben. So.
Ähm und aus dieser Anti-Zensur-Geste, die du auf gegenüber Russland aufgeführt hat oder oder sozusagen ähm ja sich da öffentlich sehr stark exponiert hat und das gesagt hat, rührt eben offenbar auch die Vermutung, dass es das für,
ähm.
Für Deutschland auch nicht, nicht gäbe und das ist halt auch nicht ganz unbegründet. Also es ist es ist eigentlich verrückt, wenn du dir das überlegst, aber äh zu Zeiten von von Old School Society, ähm diesem Verfahren gegen diese rechtsterroristische Gruppe kam halt raus, dass der General Bundesanwalt, ja,
nicht weiß, wo Telegram sitzt. Also im Juli zweitausendsechzehn schreiben die,
der Betreiber des Internetdienstes konnte bislang nicht ermittelt werden, weil sich weder die Unternehmensform noch ein Impressum, eine Geschäftsadresse oder relevante Serverstandorte feststellen lassen.
So, inzwischen gibt es diese Adresse in Dubai von der Firma, ähm aber das musst du dir halt mal vorstellen, das ist verrückt, das ist ein Messenger, der viele Millionen Nutzerinnen und Nutzer hat.
Und es ist ja das eine, wenn man als Tech-Unternehmen irgendwie sagt, weiß ich nicht, bei bestimmten Sachen arbeiten wir nicht mit dem Staat zusammen, wie wie Apple das macht, so, aber es ist halt das andere, wenn dann
eine Behörde einfach keine Ahnung hat, wo du überhaupt bist.
Da hätten wir jetzt noch eine Frage direkt von AJ, die mich auch tatsächlich interessieren würde. Ähm
zur letzten Sendung kommentierte AJ. Tim hat gesagt, die wollen ihre Nutzer behalten, damit sie Geld verdienen. Ähm weiß eigentlich jemand, womit Telegram überhaupt Geld verdient?
Telekom ist kostenlos, Telegramm ist werbefrei. Ähm von daher muss man wohl davon ausgehen, dass das Unternehmen selbst kein.
Abwirft. Ähm hat in Anhörungen gesagt, äh Pavel Duo,
dass er ähm bis äh zweitausendsiebzehn äh das gesamte Unternehmen alle Kosten aus seinem Privatvermögen.
Bezahlt hat. Ähm zweihundertachtzehn Millionen Dollar habe er an Telegram investiert. Das klingt nach einer wahnsinnig riesigen Summe.
Aber das ist ja Multimilliardär.
Ja, es ist nicht völlig unlausibel, also laut Farbsrangliste äh gilt als der reichste Mensch Dubais.
Das ist ein Ort, an dem nicht gerade wenig reiche Menschen leben, so der ist knapp, der ist knapp über den Top hundert der reichsten Menschen der Welt,
und ähm der Verkauf von V-Kontakte, nachdem er dort rausgedrängt wurde, hat nach Schätzung dreihundert bis vierhundert Millionen,
Dollar eingebracht, so zu dem Zeitpunkt ähm mit achtundzwanzig Jahren, sagt er selber, habe er über hunderte Millionen verfügt.
Und von daher, ja, das ist aber, das ist aber interessant, weil äh trotzdem haben die ein Problem,
langfristig Geld zu verdienen. Und in irgendeiner Form muss Telegramm Geld erlösen, ist ja das Problem, vor dem ähm Facebook auch mit WhatsApp steht, auch seit sie denen einen ähm Euro, den das äh den obligatorischen einen Euro, den das am Anfang gekostet hat, äh aufgelöst haben,
und ähm in öffentlichen Kanälen soll,
Werbung angezeigt werden. Das hat für viel aussehen sollst, dass du auf kurz vor Weihnachten zwanzig zwanzig äh sozusagen öffentlich gesagt.
Über seinen Telegram Kanal und spannenderweise ist das einer der Punkte, die das Bundesamt für Justiz ähm eine dem Justizministerium untergeordnete,
Behörde in Bonn auch auf den Plan gerufen hat, Telegramm unter das Netzwerkdurchsetzungsgesetz zu fassen. Die haben gesagt, ah, da ist eine Gewinnerzielungsabsicht, wie das dann so schön heißt im Juristendeutsch und ähm
Deswegen ist das sozusagen auch vielleicht mehr eine kommerzielle und öffentliche Plattform als uns bisher aus irgendeinem Grund aufgefallen ist, obwohl das würde ich argumentieren, auch schon vorher erkennbar war, dass das auch eine öffentliche Plattform ist. Und deswegen wollen wir Telegram und das Netz DG fassen,
und äh das haben sie auch Telegramm mitgeteilt in in dem Schreiben, was sozusagen über den Rechtshilfeersuchenweg nach Dubai ging. Und das ist natürlich total krass, wenn man sich das vorstellt,
weil das würde bedeuten, nach Netzt DG muss ja ab Februar zwanzig zweiundzwanzig ähm jede Plattform, die da drunter fällt, äh Daten
an das Bundeskriminalamt melden. Also wenn da eine bestimmte Straftat erfüllt wird
Müssen die sagen, hier ist der Post, hier ist die IP-Adresse, ähm ich glaube auch, hier ist die Portnummer. Ich weiß nicht, ob man verpflichtend ist oder nur, wenn sie es vorhalten, ähm aber sie können das auf jeden Fall, es ist legal, die die Portnummer da weiterzuschicken. Ähm und hier ist der Nutzerinnen oder Nutzername dieser Person,
So und dann ich kann mir schwer vorstellen, wie Pavel Dura von sein Unternehmen sich dem beugen werden so, aber das ist das, was das Netz DG und was der deutsche Staat von Telegram verlangt.
Es gibt ja noch, wir haben jetzt über viele illegale Inhalte gesprochen. Wir müssen jetzt gleich auch echt einfach mal zu den positiven Effekten kommen. Ah, kommen wir nochmal zu einer Kategorie noch schlimmerer Inhalte.
Ähm die ja auch ähm üblicherweise in geschlossenen Foren.
Oder im sogenannten Darknet äh häufig verteilt werden. Und zwar um dokumentierten Kindesmissbrauch. Wie wie stehen sie denn denn da?
Also es gibt zwei Sachen, wo sie öffentlich gesagt haben, ähm schon lange, dass die auf Telegram, also dass sie dagegen vorgehen, auf Telegram, das eine ist islamistischer Terror und das andere ist Kindesmissbrauch.
Und das soll man melden, man kann Inhalte melden nach pornografischen, also sozusagen weil sie Pornographie darstellen sollen,
Es ist allerdings so, dass Telegram,
laut Ermittlern keine Meldungen an Neck Mac Macht, Neckmac National Center for Missing and Explorer Children ist eine Nichtregierungsorganisation in den USA und die ist so die Zentrale,
Schnittstelle, ähm die sozusagen äh die Meldung dann weitergibt an die lokalen Länderbehörden und von da aus fangen ganz, ganz viele äh Ermittlungen im Bereich Kindesmissbrauch,
ähm sexualisierte Gewalt gegen Kinder äh deutschlandweit zum Beispiel an. Also es sind es gibt Tage, da kommen irgendwie hundert Meldungen von Neckmack in in Deutschland an mit einer IP-Adresse eben,
und ich würde jetzt argumentieren, also wenn das sozusagen stimmt, was was die Ermittler da sagen und was wir da recherchieren konnten, dann ist das schon schon erstaunlich, weil.
Eigentlich jedes große Tech-Unternehmen meldet an Neckmack.
Ähm und wenn du wirklich dagegen vorgehen willst, ich will gar nicht unterstellen, dass die das nicht wirklich wollen, aber es ist ein relativ einfacher Schritt, zu sagen
melden Dinge an um dafür zu sorgen, dass Ermittlungen überall auf der Welt, im Bereich Kindesmissbrauch eben anfangen können. Das fand ich schon erstaunlich, dass sie das eben nicht
nicht machen offenkundig, wenn das so stimmt, was die Ermittler da sagen.
Also es gibt eine Position und ich bin äh dieser Position immer wieder auch persönlich nicht unbedingt abgeneigt zu sagen, dass äh wenn es etwas gibt,
dass es äh eben so ist und dass es nicht besser wird, dadurch, dass man es irgendwie aus der, aus der Öffentlichkeit verdrängt. Das kann
zum Beispiel den Handel mit illegalisierten Substanzen betreffen das kommt aber natürlich an,
sehr harte Grenzen, wenn man über dokumentierten Kindesmissbrauch und irgendwie Terrorismus und Verwendung äh verfassungs äh feindlicher Symbole und so weiter denkt, ne? Gleichzeitig ähm
gibt es immer wieder eine, also sagen wir mal, die Libertäre Perspektive hat äh durchaus hm
auch einige äh Fakten, die für ihre Argumente sprechen
So und ähm gleichzeitig äh machen wir uns ja auch immer Sorge, dass wenn gegen etwas vorgegangen wird, ähm dass es dabei zu einem
Potentiell größeren.
Negativen Effekt für das Gute kommt als äh zu einem positiven Effekt durch das äh Bekämpfen des Schlechten. Und äh während wir jetzt sehr viel über
spezifische gesellschaftliche Phänomene auf Telegram gesprochen haben, gibt es ja eine ganze Menge Nutzerinnen weltweit, die ähm
vielleicht da andere Inhalte behandeln als ein paar äh Prepper, paar Querdenker, paar Nazis und ein paar Drogen äh Händlerinnen. Ähm,
Was ist also und und und diese diese Position müssen wir irgendwie auch so ein bisschen mal,
hier äh berücksichtigen, weil die kamen jetzt ein bisschen zu kurz, ne? Weil eigentlich ja ähm wenn jemand hingeht und sagt, ich mache hier eine Zensur freie Plattform. Das einzige, was ich verbiete, ist äh islamistischer Terror und dokumentierter Kindesmissbrauch oder dagegen gehe ich vor. Alles andere
ist hier das ist ja eine Position, die in den in den USA durchaus auch verbreitet ist, ja?
Und für die wir uns auch in der westlichen Gesellschaft eigentlich sehr viel äh Rühmen für die Meinungs oder in den USA sogar Redefreiheit.
Hast total recht, ja? Also die ähm,
ich würde noch hinzufügen, wenn du sagst, sozusagen ein paar Querdenker, ein paar Rechtsextreme und so weiter. Also die Gruppen haben hunderttausend Mitglieder und mehr von diesen neuen.
Und die wirklich längst auch ins Rechtsextreme und und Waffen befürworten, abgedriftenen Leute wie Xavier, Naidoo, wie ähm oder also Atlan Hildmann, der hat halt da echt kurz vor seiner Abschaltung irgendwie gesagt, hier Armbrust,
hast dein Recht auf Verteidigung, hier nochmal ein Affiliate-Link und hier der Link zum Shop,
los geht's so ungefähr, also das ist schon nicht bloß ein Paar, das ist eine sehr große Öffentlichkeit, das muss man in der Abwägung natürlich mit.
Bedenken, aber.
Hast total Recht, wir haben in unserer Recherche und in dem was wir jetzt bisher erzählt haben und auch in unseren Artikel beim Spiegel natürlich sehr viel die düsteren Seiten gezeigt und versucht auszuleuchten und das finde ich auch wichtig, weil ich nicht glaube, dass die Öffentlichkeit, dass die Öffentlichkeit das so weit,
klar ist was dort alles passiert und und möglich ist und in welchem Ausmaß. Aber gleichzeitig steht natürlich auch auf dem.
Spiel der der Kampf gegen äh Diktaturen in repressiven Ländern, also die Demokratiebewegung in Weißrussland kann man glaube ich sagen, hätte vermutlich ohne Telegram nicht den gleichen,
öffentlichen Wumms gehabt, also dieser ähm.
Kanalbetreiber eines äh des Nektar-Kanals, der dort äh mit der abgefahrenen Ryanair-Maschine festgenommen wurde, also der Mitbetreiber des Kanals ähm.
Das war einer der Kanäle der Polizeigewalt und Gewalt, der der Sicherheitskräfte äh öffentlich gemacht hat. Christina Hebel vorm Spiegel hat da auch irgendwie öfter mit dem geredet und das recherchiert und und irgendwie das gut gut gezeigt finde ich, dass.
Welche wichtige Rolle Telegramm da wirklich gespielt hat, um einfach weltweit öffentlich zu machen, was an Repressionen ähm und an Unterdrückung von
demokratischem, pro-demokratischen Protest in Weißrussland stattfindet, genauso im Iran,
ist das gewesen, genauso in Hongkong, Tim, du hast es erwähnt und auch in anderen Ländern in Russland, Ukraine haben wir angesprochen, es ist Telegram einfach eine eine wichtige Plattform von prodemokratischen.
Bewegungen und das muss man auf jeden Fall auch mitbedenken.
Die Frage ist, ist das jetzt eine eine implizite Leistung von oder eine explizite Leistung von Telegram.
Ja? Oder ist es sozusagen nur, dass am einfachsten zu erreichen im Medium und es würden sich vielleicht auch Alternativen schnell herausbilden, wenn das jetzt nicht gerade diesen Bereich abdecken würde, Kraft seiner derzeitigen Reichweite?
Es gibt Hand in Hand, würde ich fast sagen, also wenn man sozusagen über die Leistung von Telegram spricht, muss man auf jeden Fall auch sagen und das ist auch was total positives, das ist einfach ein,
ähm objektiv betrachtet, jetzt ein paar Sicherheitsfragen und Opsek oder Sicherheitsfragen mal kurz zur Seite gestellt, einfach Objektivbedarf, ein sehr, sehr guter,
technisch innovativer, gut funktionierender Messenger, der, der immer erreichbar,
fast immer eigentlich fast immer erreichbar ist. Die hatten total früh neue Funktionen, also diese
Stickersets auf Telegram, die machen einfach total viel Spaß. Äh weiß nicht, diese Angela Merkel äh Sticker, die man sich da hin und her schicken kann, diese Customizicker, die man erstellen kann, so
Hat da lustige Sticker sich erstellt und und jeder kann das sozusagen machen, jeder und jede und das kann ist eine total unterhaltsame Form der Kommunikation, ähm die hatten vor WhatsApp, äh Ende zu Ende verschlüsselte,
Chats angeboten, die man speziell aktivieren muss, ja, also nicht alles war eine Verschlüsselung, wie es dann auf WhatsApp kam, aber das war sozusagen schon. Ähm.
Die sind einfach technisch total innovativ und ein Beispiel, was man vielleicht auch noch erwähnen sollte, hm, die russischen Behörden haben auch im Zuge so eine es gab natürlich dann auch weiter Intermezzos nachdem Durov sozusagen,
Russland verlassen hat oder um die Welt, also der der kehrt immer noch ab und zu nach Russland,
zurück äh gibt es Vermutungen, aber zumindest sozusagen dem sich da vom Kreml den Kreml öffentlich kritisiert hat und da irgendwie sich zum Dissidenten gemacht hat, ähm.
Mit seinen öffentlichen Äußerungen äh gab es natürlich auch noch Telegramm. Und äh die russischen Behörden haben halt Telegramm versucht zu sperren und ähm auch aus Kombination, die,
russische Telekommunikationsbehörde bisschen Äquivalent wie die Bundesnetzagentur im weitesten Sinne haben halt angeordnet das zu sperren und die haben halt Russland vor den Augen der Welt vorgeführt. Es gab auch einen guten Vortrag darüber äh auf dem.
Letzten Chaos, Computer-Kongress, ich weiß gar nicht mehr, wann war der letzte zweitausendneunzehn muss es dann gewesen sein? Ähm,
ähm der einfach zeigt, wie technisch ähm stark die das geschafft haben, denen Zensurversuchen Russlands, die ja nun auch,
den großen Hammer an der Hand haben, zu entgehen und das hat dazu geführt, dass sozusagen russische Banken gesperrt wurden, ähm weiß ich nicht, offizielle russische Museen vom Netz gehen mussten, aber Telegram war die ganze Zeit online.
So, das haben sie sich Geld kosten lassen, aber das haben sie auch mit mit technischer Raffinesse, sage ich mal, geschafft. Also da sind schon sehr, sehr kundige,
Programmierer am Werk hinter dieser App und das ist ja auf jeden Fall auch was Gutes.
Ich glaube äh es könnte sein, dass es nicht dass es der vorletzte live war. Also ich finde nur äh ein äh beim fünfunddreißig C dreiundzwanzig achtzehn, nicht beim sechsunddreißig C drei zwanzig neunzehn.
Ja crusher versus telegram technical notes on the Battle fünfunddreißig C drei, du hast Recht.
Ja super, haben wir verlinkt in den Shownotes.
Also ich finde, die größere Frage, die halt hier zu diskutieren ist, ähm ich weiß nicht, ihr habt ja letztes Mal auch aufgerufen, ob da irgendwie Hörerinnen und Hörer was dazu gesagt haben. Ist halt ähm.
Wie weit sollte ein.
Unternehmen mit dem Staat kooperieren oder wie weit sollte es das nicht? Ähm wo sollte da irgendwie der Staat einschreiten.
Ist das akzeptabel, dass ein Unternehmen sich soweit entzieht, dass teilweise nicht mal die Adresse.
Bekannt ist, ich meine, wir sind im Zug unserer Recherche, es ähm auch ist jemand aus unserem Team vor Ort gewesen in in Dubai und an der Adresse, die angeblich jetzt zu Telegram gehören soll, haben wir halt auch niemanden angetroffen und dann sagt irgendwie die Empfangsdame, ist total komisch, wir haben.
Sie sind hier in unserem System, aber es kommt nie jemand von denen. Also so ist das akzeptabel für ein Tech-Unternehmen, dass man so gar nicht ansprechbar ist offenkundig oder sich so weit entzieht.
Ähm wie weit sollte man als Unternehmerinnen und Staat kooperieren? Das ist schon, finde ich, eine Frage, die sich bei Telegram sehr stellt.
Vielleicht dazu mal ein Kommentar von Chris zur letzten Sendung. Wie gesagt, noch mal äh äh die von mir geäußerte Hypothese, dass Apple Google Attila Hildmann gesperrt hätten, war eine Hypothese und Wax hat ja schon gesagt, gibt eigentlich
irgendwie keine kein Beleg dafür. Apple und Google sagen es war nicht so. Telegram sagt gar nichts. Äh und jetzt zur Frage, ne, was wollen wir für staatliche Kontrolle? Äh Chris sagt zum Thema Telegram. Auf der einen Seite finde ich das super.
Auch wenn man den Kanal weiterhin sieht, wenn man die App für Android,
zum Beispiel von hat, aber auf der anderen Seite macht es mir schon Sorge, dass Zensur von diversen Unternehmen oder Staaten ohne weiteres,
durchgedrückt werden kann. Ich habe da die Befürchtung, dass sich das auch auf unsere freie Meinung negativ
wirken wird, wenn das zum Defeult wird, ne? Das ist ja da unter dieser Begründung würde man ja sagen, nee, dann ist das schon ganz okay, dass dieses Unternehmen bitte alles tut, um sich den den staatlichen Zugriffen irgendwie zu entziehen.
Also ich finde am am Beispiel hielt man, muss man sich halt einfach angucken, was dort ähm geteilt wurde. Also.
Da sind Beleidigungen von Personen am laufenden Band, dass einfach eine Gewalt befürwortende Haltung, also man kann halt echt.
Konnte in einer Echtzeitradikalisierung da zugucken auf Telegram, die schon unheimlich auch war. Ähm da sind diese Waffen, die eben beworben werden mit du hast ein Recht auf Widerstand äh angeblich.
Und da sind wir halt schon in einem Bereich, wo man jetzt vom deutschen Strafgesetzbuch her sagen würde.
Nicht alles da ist von der von der Meinungsfreiheit gedeckt. Die Sachen, die ich gerade gesagt habe, vielleicht schon noch, aber die verfassungsfeindlichen Kennzeichen oder die ähm ähm Reichs äh Reichsbürgersympathien, die irgendwie auch mit Kennzeichen ausgedruckt wurde, da,
kommt man halt schon so in in den Grenzbereich. Also ich find's ich würde immer sagen, wenn man jetzt nehme ich nach meiner persönlichen Meinung fragt, dass es einfach.
Entscheidend ist, dass es eine bestimmte Möglichkeit gibt, äh vom Staat.
Also in demokratischen Ländern dafür zu sorgen, dass bestimmte strafbare Inhalte nicht große Verbreitungen im Netz finden können, allerdings der Katalog, was dort als Strafbau bezeichnet ist, der ist total entscheidend und der muss gut.
Eingeschränkt und und gut begründet sein und ich finde es so wichtig, dass sozusagen.
Da eine gewisse Möglichkeit besteht für für Staaten, die in eben demokratisch gewählt sind, weil,
demokratisch konstituierte Staaten sind, wenn es eine andere Partei gibt, die eine andere Haltung hat,
und das ist eine gesellschaftliche Mehrheit dafür gibt, dass wir diese Inhalte doch im Internet haben wollen, dann kann sich das dadurch ändern, dass das Netz DG dann zum Beispiel geändert werden würde. Darüber, was Pawedoo auf sein Unternehmen tun würden, haben wir einfach keine keinerlei von,
demokratische Handhabe, klar Hausrecht, wir können die App nicht benutzen, aber die App ist so groß, dass sie eben Auswirkungen zu haben, droht auf demokratischen Diskurs teilweise. Es gibt deutsche Behörden, die befürchten, dass es,
Nachrichten Auswirkungen auf die Bundestagswahl haben werden von von Telegram. Also das ist einfach eine eine Flughöhe, wo es nicht mehr darum geht,
das ist nur ein privater Messenger, sondern das ist auch ein öffentlicher Raum.
Immer das ist immer wieder so einkehrendes Thema auch, ne, man, wenn man jetzt mal äh so ein bisschen auch in die.
Und Tradition
Auch der Hacker Bewegung schaut in in Deutschland, das war immer alles extrem von dieser Grundüberzeugung geprägt, ne, so Hackerethik äh Informationen müssen frei fließen et cetera und
da steckt sicherlich ein guter Ansatz drin, ne? Und das ist ja auch immer alles enorm davon getragen, von so einem Grundmisstrauen gegen Autoritäten,
ne? Auch das steht genauso in der Hakaethik äh drin. Und da ist sicherlich eine Menge dran, ne. So dieses Bild eines ähm
überbordenden, alles kontrollierenden Staates, der also der Bad Actor ist, müssen wir nicht weit in der Geschichte zurückblättern, um zu wissen, warum das in Deutschland äh gerade so ein so ein starkes Thema ist, ne? Ganz klar. Und es ist sicherlich auch eine Bedrohung und die will ich auch gar nicht weg,
Allerdings sieht man ja jetzt auch,
Es ist beileibe nicht die einzige Gefahr, die eine einer Gesellschaft ausgesetzt ist, sondern wir haben jetzt eben ähm auch das Gegenproblem,
in gewisser Hinsicht so eine unregulierte unbeobachtete Kommunikationsplattform.
Leuten äh Raum gibt, die vielleicht, wo der Konsens der Gesellschaft auch eher sagen würde, so ah nee, also da müssen wir schon.
Irgendeiner Form ein Mitspracherecht haben und das drückt sich ja dann,
Ende am ehesten durch Gesetze und Regulierung des Staates und im Zweifelsfall halt auch der
äh kontrollierenden äh ausführenden Behörden aus so und klar, man muss immer den den richtig die richtige Balance finden und sicherlich trauen auch nicht alle
dem Staat äh zu immer die richtige Balance zu finden. Sie äh,
Jüngste Gerichts äh Gesetzesbeschlüsse im Bundestag, die wir hier noch gar nicht gesprochen haben. Und das ist so ein
jetzt haben wir das tolle Wort, so ein Spannungsfeld, ich glaube, in der auch die Szene selber steht, ne? Ich will jetzt nicht nur über die Hackerszene reden, sondern sagen wir mal grundsätzlich äh so eine aufgeklärte,
Gesellschaft, die ähm jetzt nicht unbedingt alles brennen sehen möchte.
Die durchaus ein Interesse an unregulierter freier Kommunikation hat, aber die ähm auf der anderen Seite auch genauso ein Interesse daran hat, dass nicht alle komplett
äh durchgedrehen und und und äh also antidemokratische Tendenzen damit gefördert werden.
Weiß nicht, wie was zu was für eine Erkenntnis du da gekommen bist, ob wir da überhaupt eine Chance haben, äh da die Balance zu finden, beziehungsweise wenn.
Auf welche Art und Weise man diese Balance finden kann.
Tja, das ist wirklich die die Frage, ne? Man muss das dann sich auch immer im.
Im Einzelfall angucken ist auch so 'ne Floskel und die nächste Floskel ist irgendwie so.
Das Internet darf kein rechtsfreier Raum sein, mit der die Politik immer um die Ecke kommt und gleichzeitig finde ich, ist Telegram so das beste Beispiel, dass sie halt so.
Sehenden Auges hinterherhinken und halt jetzt sagen, jetzt sagt das Justizministerium A,
Telegramm ist doch auch ein öffentlicher Raum. Das Netzwerkdurchsetzungsgesetz ist ja gedacht gewesen zur Regulierung von
Social Media Plattform. Am Anfang hieß es, dass Facebook Gesetz und Masters versucht hat, aufzugleisen und die irgendwie äh mehr dazu zu bringen, hm besser und konsistenter zu moderieren.
Und ähm.
Finde ich, ist zumindest ein in der in der Stufe ein erster richtiger Gedanke gewesen, weil die Straftaten auch umrissen sind, die dort moderiert werden sollen,
ähm die müssen das irgendwie in Berichten transparent machen, wie viel sie löschen, leider sind die Anforderungen ziemlich schlecht und die umgehen das sozusagen. Und jetzt hat man aber irgendwie Jahre später erst gemerkt, so dass Telegramm halt auch dieser öffentliche Raum ist.
Und das ist halt ja, da.
Da würde man sich halt einfach wünschen, aber das ist nun mal in der Natur der Sache von demokratischen Debatten und von Gesetzesinitiativen in äh in Demokratien, dass es halt dauert.
Dass da irgendwie schneller agiert werden würde.
Finde halt das Ausmaß an.
Strafbaren Inhalten und an wirklich extremistischen und terroristischen Inhalten, die auf Telegram sind.
Macht es ganz klar. Es geht ja nicht darum, pauschal irgendwie die Redefreiheit auf Telegram einzuschränken, sondern es geht darum, Straftaten zu verhindern.
Und ähm das macht es notwendig, dass.
Der Staat gegenüber dieser Bedrohung, die aus bestimmten Ecken des Netzes kommen kann und gerade eben von Telegram auch kommt, wehrhafter ist.
Als er es heute ist, it's muss will ich auch noch hinzufügen.
Um jetzt nicht nur dem Wunsch nach schärferer Regulierung und staatlichen äh sozusagen äh Gesetzesinitiativen hier das Wort zu reden die ganze Zeit. Man muss halt auch sagen.
Es ist.
Nicht unbedingt so, dass Deutsche Ermittlungsbehörden, das ist ja der weniger invasive Ansatz, Telegram genug auf dem Schirm haben. Wir haben jetzt am Anfang darüber gesprochen, dass sie diese.
Rechtsterroristische Oldschool zur Zeit, jeder sich aufgeschaltet haben.
Dass es danach noch ein paar weitere Male passiert bei so äh terroristischen äh.
Terror, also bei bei Terrorvorwürfen, wenn wenn da eine richterliche Erlaubnis vorlag,
Der Verfassungsschutz verschiedene Verfassungsschutzämter haben immer mal wieder gesagt, ja wir beobachten jetzt ein paar Querdenkergruppen und so. Aber ich habe mit dem Miro Dietrich ähm
dem ich schon ähm gesagt habe, äh auch gesprochen und das hat's jetzt auch nicht in Artikel geschafft, aber er sagt halt auch, es gibt halt Fälle
wo er halt einfach mit O sind, mit Open Source Intelligence genau auf die unter anderem von dir äh von euch beschriebenen Profilbilder, die man teilweise sehen kann, wenn Leute was posten,
herausfindet, wer die Nutzerinnen und Nutzer sind, die in Gruppen nach Waffenfragen in terroristischen Gruppen und dann findet er, wie die heißen,
und äh die Accounts gibt's offenkundig immer noch und er hat beschrieben, dass es mehrere solcher Fälle gibt und man hat irgendwie nichts Gefühl,
äh ohne dass ich das jetzt belegen kann, aber dass die Behörden damit.
Derselben, also Ermittlungsbehörden mit der letzten Konsequenz wirklich dieses Problem ernst nehmen und das wäre ja eine weniger invasive,
Geschichte als jetzt äh so ein Gesetz wie das Netz die GG, was pauschal die gesamte Kommunikation von Telegram reguliert, ne, dass man das wäre ja der erste Schritt, wenn wir sagen, wir wollen als Staat wehrhaft sein gegen ähm Straftaten, gegen antidemokratische
verfassungsfeindliche Initiativen, dann würde man sich wünschen, dass Verfassungsschutz im Vorfeld und Ermittlungsbehörden, sozusagen, wenn's äh wenn's Straftaten
begangen, geplant werden, einschreiten und ich weiß nicht, ob das, ich kann schwer sagen, dass das wirklich in ausreichendem.
Maße passiert, was also ausreichend in dem Sinne, was es eben an an krassen Sachen auf Telegramm gibt, auch auf an deutschen Sachen so, also äh auch Waffen, Waffenangebote gibt's da zum Beispiel.
Merodittrich war bei der Amadeu Antonio Stiftung und äh Monitor irgendwie den deutschen äh rechten die deutsche Rechtsextreme populistische Szene, ne?
Genau, Myro Dietrich hängt auch sehr viel auf Telegram ab, um sozusagen diese Szene zum Monitor und der hat äh zusammen mit mit äh anderen Mitstreiterinnen und Mitstreitern äh äh die Cemas Organisation gegründet, Center for Monitoring
ähm noch irgendwas. Sorry, ich habe das die Abkürzung gerade nicht ganz aufm Schirm, aber.
Center, Center für Monitoring, Analyse und Strategie.
Genau, danke dir. Ähm genau, die haben sie haben sich von ähm von einer äh kürzeren Zeit gegründet und der hat auch für den äh für jetzt für unseren Spiegelartikel eine eine Analyse, haben die gemacht zusammen mit Josef Hollenburger, der auch bei der Organisation ist,
wo sie eben auch ähm ja sich diese Gruppen nochmal angeguckt haben und zum Beispiel die Verbindung zwischen so so großen Bekannten ähm rechten Gruppen wie Xavier Naidoo, Oliver Jannich.
Apologeten ähm oder eben Attila Hildmann zu äh Terroraninheiten, also zum Beispiel Xavier Naidoo teilt hundert mehr als hundertfünfzig Mal Inhalte aus besonders extremistischen Kanälen oder so so Schiffren, wie so so Nürnberg zwei null,
ähm oder tribonal, das sind so ja, klingt für Außenstehende vielleicht jetzt gar nicht so so krass, aber das bedeutet halt letztlich,
in solch in dem Kontext solcher Gruppen, die halt immer wieder vom Umsturz reden. Wir werden die Macht ergreifen und danach werden die Politiker und die öffentlichen Personen und die Journalisten und die Gutmenschen, meinetwegen auch, werden hängen,
oder mindestens ins Gefängnis eingesperrt werden. Also es sind indirekte Morddrohungen. So, das hat auch massiv zugenommen, hat sich verzehnfacht in den.
Letzten Monaten laut deren Analyse. So und das,
dieses Gefährdungspotential würde eigentlich aus meiner Sicht bedeuten, dass Ermittlungsbehörden da sehr genau hingucken müssen und das sollte immer und das wollte ich eben sagen, irgendwie die erste Stufe sein, bevor man über Gesetze redet, die die gesamte Kommunikation von Telegram regulieren. Das ist natürlich der zweite Schritt, da.
Jetzt auch eine Diskussion, weil Deutschland da jetzt irgendwie vorgeprescht ist mit diesem, dass das und das Netz WG fallen soll, aber.
Der Staat kann halt nicht immer nur sagen, ja okay, noch ein Gesetz, noch ein Gesetz, noch ein Gesetz, um irgendwie äh da die gesamte Kommunikation einzuschränken, sondern er muss, finde ich, auch nachweisen, dass er selber seine Hausaufgaben macht, um äh ja, Straftaten oder Angriffe auf,
auf ihn, auf die Demokratie zu unterbinden. Und da würde ich jetzt nicht unbedingt attestieren, dass die Hausaufgabenminder eins plus gemacht werden.
Vielleicht noch einfach um wir haben viel über ja,
bisher nur über Meinungsäußerungen äh gesprochen. Diese gesamte Telegramgruppen
Querdenkerei und so weiter, spielt natürlich auch dann eben da eine Rolle, wo die Gewalt äh tatsächlich wird, ähm an der Stelle einen Podcast Empfehlungen
den New York Times hat jetzt ein Podcast vor ein paar Wochen angefangen, der mit dem Titel Day X,
ähm in dem diese gesamte Geschichte um diese Hannibal-Gruppe und Franco A und diese ja,
rechten rechtsideologischen Leute, die sich irgendwie für den Umsturz ernsthaft vorbereitet haben und das eben auch sehr ausführlich in äh Telegram äh Gruppen.
Da sieht man.
Ja, dass es eben nicht nur dabei bleibt, dass Leute sich vielleicht mal irgendwie äh ein Gramm Gas gegen Spotify tauschen oder mal ein Hakenkreuz posten, sondern sich eben auch,
ja, dass das irgendwo potenziell auch tatsächlich manifestiert, was diese äh Spinner sich da ausdenken und ähm was sie.
Vorhaben.
Ja, auch diese Verherrlichung von Amokläufen, also wenn irgendwie Meroditrich als Experte, der das beobachtet sagt, das ist die ähm,
düsterste, das ist wie zu seinen schlimmsten Zeiten da gerade in manchen Terrogrammkanälen und das ist halt das heißt halt, ich meine es sind mehrere Attentäter aus dieser Szene rausgekommen, Pauly.
Ähm Halle letztlich auch äh und so weiter und so fort und jetzt halt äh wieder in Armut-Läufer oder ein verhinderter Amokläufer den Warmarkt-Shooting machen wollte, Christchurch-Style, ähm äh der sozusagen in dieser Szene gefeiert wird.
Das ist nicht einfach nur das ist nicht Meinungsfreiheit, so worum's da geht, sondern da geht's halt wirklich um Angriffe mit Waffen. Natürlich ist es total schwer, die Grenze zu ziehen und das zu entdecken, auch jetzt gerade bei dieser Agen Sache.
Ich meine, ich beneide die Ermittlerinnen und Ermittler da auch nicht unbedingt immer um ihren Job, wenn die halt sagen müssen, okay, weiß nicht, heißt
Optiks am Going Inn, ne, damit begann eines der Manie sogenannten Manifeste, also dieser dieser diffusen Dinger, die dann da immer gepostet werden, von einem Attentäter, heißt das jetzt, okay.
Töte jetzt so und so viele Leute maximal und versuche sie umzubringen oder ist es auch doch nur wieder irgendein Miemen. Das ist natürlich auch nicht einfach. Aber wie gesagt, ich es fällt mir schwer.
Festzustellen, dass die Bemühungen absolut konsequent da sind, um da.
Ähm das auf dem Schirm zu haben und dieser Day Ex Podcast und Hannibal Komplex zeigt es ja eigentlich auch,
gut, wie das wie der Staat da nicht konsequent genug vorgeht oder die Ermittlungsbehörden.
Auch an anderen Stellen leider, ne.
Also nicht nur bei bei Telegram-Monitoring, also ich war in der aktuellen Folge äh stellt sich raus, dass dieser Franco A irgendwie so ein Rassetheoretisch äh Nationalsozialistisch
Tischchen
Aufsatz geschrieben hat im Rahmen seiner Ausbildung bei der Bundeswehr und die haben das äh haben ihnen dann gesagt, ja nee, äh das das kannst du so nicht abgeben. Äh und dann hat der gesagt, naja okay, dann schreibt da etwas, was äh in in Übereinstimmung mit dem
mit der Verfassung der Bundesrepublik Deutschland ist und dann haben sie gesagt alles klar dann bewerten wir halt das und da da wird halt an vielen Ebenen leider offenbar bei bei,
klar erkennbar extremistischen, nicht, nicht wirklich hingeschaut. Ja Max, jetzt,
viel darüber geredet, äh aber jetzt sag mal, wie so wie kann ich denn jetzt bei Telegram äh sicher sein?
Ich wollte die Frage schon immer mal jemand anders stellen.
Obsek für die Drogengruppen auf deinem ähm Burner Gerät.
Also es gibt halt einen total großes Missverständnis, äh was dem viele Leute äh aufsitzen vielleicht nicht so sehr in der,
Szene, aber weil Telegramm immer so als Krypto Messenger ähm firmierte, ne? Und als der Messenger, der des des IS liebster Messenger ähm,
gibt es das Missverständnis, dass alle glauben, alles sei dort mit der gleichen Verschlüsselung geschützt wie bei WhatsApp oder bei Signal oder bei anderen großen Messengern,
also mit Ende zu Ende verschlüsselt und das ist nicht der Fall. Man muss Ende zu Ende Verschlüsselung dezidiert aktivieren mit dem sogenannten Geheimchat oder Secret Chat, wenn man's auf Englisch eingestellt hat. Gruppen,
und Kanäle können nie Ende zu Ende verschlüsselt sein
ähm und normale Chats, weiß ich nicht, wenn wenn wir jetzt wenn man seine Kontakte synchronisiert hätte und und Dinos wir, da ich da die Nummer von deinem Burner-Phone kennen würde und ich sehe und du siehst irgendwie, ah ja, Max Hottenstädt auch da und du schreibst mich an. Dieser Chat ist erstmal nicht Ende zu Ende verschlüsselt,
und und liegt halt deshalb in Kopie äh auf der Cloud von Telegram, wo Telegram sozusagen sagt, wir geben diese Nutzerdaten nicht raus und haben das nie getan,
ähm und natürlich sitzen die die auch, die Server und sind auch keine Fälle bekannt, dass es da irgendwie zu zu Leaks kam oder so, aber es ist eben halt ein anderes Schutzniveau als Ende zu Ende verschlüsselt und das wäre sozusagen der erste Punkt.
Ähm zu nutzen, geheime Chats, die Ende zu Ende verschlüsselt sind. Ähm.
Diese Variante mit der Accountaufschaltung, die die Ermittler genutzt haben, bei ähm der Old School Society, was natürlich auch ähm,
Kriminellen, wenn sie die SMS abfangen können, weiß ich nicht, sei es übern Schulterblick, wenn man sich jetzt so Stalking-Fälle vorstellen würde oder sei's irgendwie bei anderen Möglichkeiten. Davor kann man sich schützen, mhm indem man eine Zweifaktor-Authentifizierung für
äh einrichtet, die man eingeben muss, wenn ähm ein weiteres Gerät zugeschaltet wird.
Es gibt auch eine eine Pin-Code-Sperre, die man ähm machen kann. Genau und dann du hast es auch schon gesagt, Linos Kontakte synchronisieren. Ist aus Datenschutzsicht, ähm auch wenn wenn Telegram sozusagen keine kommerzielle Verwendung dieser Daten zu machen scheint für Werbung,
nie eine gute Idee bei Messengern, also bei WhatsApp gibt's da ja die riesen Debatte drum und das kann man bei Telegram auch einfach sein lassen, wenn man da besonders datenschutzaffin von sich aus einfach sein möchte. Wie gesagt, es gibt mich
Hinweise, dass irgendwie eine eine Data Mining oder irgendwas stattfindet auf der anderen Seite und es gibt auch keine kommerzielle Verwendung für Telegramm, diese Daten zu verticken oder so, aber man kann's halt trotzdem einfach lassen.
Aus. Ähm genau, es ist interessant finde ich diese ähm diese Abwägung zwischen Benutzbarkeit und Sicherheit
ähm hat Telegram halt auch ganz am Anfang schon getroffen. Die haben für die Ende zu Ende verschlüsselt ein eigenes Protokoll, MT, Protoprotokoll heißt das, was der ähm Bruder von Pavel Durav Nikola Durav mitgeschrieben haben soll.
Und nutzen für den Key Exchange Hellmann ähm äh und zweihundertsechsundfünfzig Bit äh symmetrische AES-Verschlüsselung, dass das sozusagen,
Das klingt erstmal äh alles gut und richtig, ist es äh und und es gibt auch eigentlich keinen wesentlichen Widerspruch von Experten dazu. Es ist halt aber trotzdem nicht das Protokoll, was äh Signal und so weiter gemacht haben,
ähm und die Abwägung zwischen Benutzbarkeit und Sicherheit ist eben in diesem Fall, dass der der Key Exchange der Schlüsselaustausch.
Der ist ja, das ist ja auch, das ist nicht trivial, ein Schlüsselaustausch in großen Gruppen hinzukriegen, ne. Ähm ich glaube, das ist auch für Signal nicht einfach gewesen,
zum Beispiel, ich weiß nicht, wie groß können die Gruppen sein, ich glaube tausend Mitglieder äh können die haben. Das ist nicht trivial, dass die alle Ende zu Ende verschlüsseln miteinander. Und bei Telegram ist die Abwägung eben, das geht gar nicht,
Du kannst deine Kanäle deswegen auf allen Geräten immer benutzen. Das ist praktisch, deine Gruppen auf allen Geräten benutzen, wenn du verschiedene Geräte hast, weil die eben nicht Ende zu Ende verschlüsselt äh Kanäle sowieso nicht, aber Gruppen auch nicht, Ende zu Ende verschlüsselt sein können. Das ist technisch einfach nicht möglich,
gibt nicht so was wie Secret Groupjet, geheimer Gruppenchat. Es gibt nur secret äh Direktnachricht sozusagen, geheime Direktnachrichten mit Ende zu Ende Verschlüsselung.
Ausgeschaltet.
Ausgeschaltet, genau.
Hm, das ist schon also, das scheint mir eines der großen,
also eines der ganz großen inhaltlichen Irrtümer zu sein, die Nutzerinnen von Telegram haben, ja, dass sie glauben, das ist verschlüsselt. Und dann kommt irgendwie noch hinzu, dass sie sich irgendwie einbilden
Verschlüsselung sie ungefähr vor allem ungemach äh schützen würde, äh dass sie sich so vorstellen können. Ähm weil, also was
ich meine, man registriert sich ja dort mit der Telefonnummer, ne? Man kann nur einschalten, dass die nicht angezeigt wird, wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe, oder?
Du kannst aber auch wechseln auf einen auf einen Nutzernamen und genau, deine Telefonnummer wird nicht nicht angezeigt und ähm.
Das sind weitere Einstellungen, die sozusagen zu empfehlen sind, wenn man Gruppen und Kanäle benutzt, da kannst du auch.
Einstellen, dass niemand sehen können soll, in was für Kanälen du bist, in was für Gruppen, also in was für Kanälen du bist, genau
ähm im Zuge der Proteste in Hongkong ähm
gab es offenbar eine, ja, so eine Art Brootforce-Abfrage durch chinesische Behörden, die halt sozusagen dadurch versucht, äh versucht haben, herauszufinden, wer in einstiegigen Protestkanälen, der, der,
Bewegung ist ähm und das hat Telegram, da hat Telegram dann nachgerüstet und schützt inzwischen davor
und das ist natürlich wichtig, weil da auch ähm nicht nur dieser Blutforstangriff, sondern auch verdeckte,
mittleren und Ermittler chinesischer Seite ist die Befürchtung, in diesen Gruppen mitlesen und dann rausfinden, damit drin sind, um rauszufinden, welche Telefonnummer die haben, das kannst du aber auch in deinen Einstellungen ausstellen. Denn eine andere Funktion
wo man auch sagen muss, Telegram echt vorne dabei ist, ist ist ähm People nee bei, die Telegram benutzen, das ist so ein bisschen so
Tinder für Messenger mäßig und halt auch Groups nebenbei. Also da gibt es nette
Experimente, die auch andere Journalistinnen, Journalistinnen gemacht haben irgendwie, weiß ich nicht, wo du dich dann halt so ans äh schlesische Tor in Berlin stellst und irgendwie guckst, wo Groups mir bei und da alleine dadurch,
erfährst du, wie die Namen der Drogengruppen heißen. Äh wo halt Leute aktiv sind in diesen Gruppen. Ähm.
Natürlich auch zu empfehlen äh äh dieses dieses also dieses das ist Pattifort ausgestellt, aber man sollte sich sehr genau überlegen, wenn man dieses Feature aktiviert, kann natürlich auch positive,
haben, weil sie nicht im Rahmen von Protesten und so, aber ja, das ist schon, sollte man sich sehr genau bewusst sein, was man da aktiviert, wenn man das aktiviert.
Ich bin hier mal kurz in den Privacy-Einstellungen auf der Desktop-App, also ich kann sagen, niemand soll meine Telefonnummer sehen. Niemand soll sehen, wann ich das letzte Mal online war.
Gruppen und Kanälen kann ich das kann ich nur limitieren auf meine Kontakte.
Also ich kann nicht sagen, niemand darf das sehen. Aber da ich keine Kontakte habe, ist es okay. Ähm ich kann sagen, meine Call, also Calls ist vielleicht äh also genau, mich kann man darüber nicht anrufen.
Und ich mach's niemals. Das ist mit Sicherheit eine ein sehr wichtiges Feature, wenn man vermeiden möchte, potenziell seine IP-Adresse zu leaken. Ähm.
Und.
Ich kann mein Profilfoto einschränken, auf meine Kontakte, ich habe aber kein Profilfoto und irgendwie Messages kann man dann auch noch ausschalten, weil man kann offenbar forwarden. Ein Feature, was ich ganz interessant finde, ist dieses Delit-My Account.
Away Four, also und das kann ich sagen, ab einem Monat. Ne, das kann natürlich ähm.
Potentiell nicht verkehrt sein, wenn man weiß, okay, ich bin, also sage ich mal, wenn man länger als einen Monat in Untersuchungshaft ist, dann möchte man vielleicht auch, dass der Telegram-Account gelöscht wird, ne?
Ja. Du kannst auch synchronisierte Kontakte wieder löschen, du kannst es halt lassen, Kontakte zu synchronisieren. Ähm und genau dieses, wenn inaktiv, du kannst auch in ähm Chats verschwindende Nachrichten einstellen, also,
Man kann also Fazit, man kann Telegramm auch auf eine sehr sichere ähm.
Geschützte Art und Weise benutzen als privater Messenger.
Ob es als absolut privat äh also als absolut sozusagen IT-Sicherheitsperfekter Messenger.
Das Niveau von anderen Messengern erreicht ungefähr, ja, vermutlich. Aber es gibt halt in den in der Standardart der Nutzung und grade in der Nutzung von Gruppen und Kanälen, also dieses,
dass nur deine Kontakte sehen können, was für Kanälen du bist, auch das kann ja schon zu viel sein. Jetzt weiß ich nicht, angenommen irgendwie, du bist in Kanälen von Sachen, die wo du nicht willst, dass deine Arbeitskolleginnen und Arbeitskollegen das wissen. So ähm und die könnten es aber darüber sehen, dass
auch das kann ja schon problematisch sein, worüber man sich vielleicht gar nicht bewusst ist. So, das ist so die die frühere Befürchtung irgendwie
meines Chefs und Chefin meine Facebook-Partyfotos sehen, ist halt jetzt so, können sie halt sehen, in was für Kanälen ich irgendwie nach Feierabend äh äh Party mache, so ungefähr.
Hat man nicht so aufm Schirm, aber es ist eine reelle Möglichkeit. Ich weiß nicht, ob Angreiferinnen, Angreifer das so aufm Zettel haben, aber.
Es lohnt sich ja sich sicherlich sich die Einstellung genau anzugucken, wenn man die die Chats äh in öffentlichen Kanälen und Gruppen auch benutzt.
Also mit mit Vorname und Nachname im Profil würde ich jetzt nicht nach zehn Gramm Gras fragen. Lieber Piep.
Ja, das ist das sehen nicht alle so lieben, das sehen nicht alle so offenbar.
Okay.
Eine Sache, die ich noch bei den technischen Funktionen total wichtig finde, also ähm die Apps sind, sind open Source bei, bei Telegram, Serverseitiger Kram ist. Ähm.
Und die haben eine Programmierschnittstelle, an die man, mit der man ziemlich viel machen kann, an die man viel ran kann. Ich weiß nicht, Berlinerinnen und Berliner kennen's vielleicht den Impfbot,
ähm der also Impftermin, Board, der dir dann irgendwie schickt, wenn wieder wo Impftermine frei sind, so was jetzt ganz oft auch über Telekom ist, es gibt super viele.
Und spannende und interessante Boards, die einfach echt, das ist technisch cool, ähm weil's sozusagen direkt auf deinem Smartphone diese Unmittelbarkeit äh der Kommunikation hat und es ist ähm.
Es ist auch eigentlich eine eine sehr sinnvolle und spannende Idee als Plattform so zu fungieren als Messenger. Ähm nur gleichzeitig ist.
Das ist tatsächlich meine einzige Anwendung, äh die ich für Telegramm habe. Äh von solchen Pots äh bespielt zu werden und mitgeteilt zu bekommen, wenn irgendwo ähm in schwer verfügbaren Bereichen Tickets zu haben sind.
Ja genau, das ist ähm das ist eigentlich auch eine total spannende und schlaue Idee, also Telegramm hat ja sogar auch versucht, ein eigenes Bezahlsystem, auch übrigens vor Facebook mit dem Library jetzt dir im genannten Projekt, ähm mit ähm.
Tonnen hieß das, Tonnen Labs ist so eine so eine Ausgründung oder Einheit oder so von Telegram, die halt auch so ein, so ein eigenes Bezahlsystem äh und ein ähm Blockchain-System.
Den Messenger etablieren wollten, kann man jetzt sozusagen von halten, was man will, ist aber aus Geschäftsperspektive und auch aus technischer Perspektive schon sehr spannend und.
Und interessant. Gleichzeitig war das sozusagen eines ihrer einer ihrer größten Fails, weil die US äh Börsenaufsicht, SEC äh das gestoppt hat.
Einer der Investoren bei ob er sein Geld zurück hat, wissen wir nicht.
Oje. Also da da sammelt sich dann auch immer direkt die Richtigen, meinst du?
Es scheint so zu sein auf jeden Fall. Die waren nur vier Etagen äh zeitweise voneinander entfernt, die Dubai, eine Dubai äh die Pendants von Wirecard und äh der Telegram Firmensitz in diesem Cassim Towern.
Diese Bot-Funktionalität äh kenne ich übrigens auch Leute, die das irgendwie
zu Hause nutzen für was weiß ich, ihr selbstgebautes Smarthome, ne, dass die Kaffeemaschine über Telegramm Bescheid sagt oder sich der äh Roboterstaubsauger über Telegramm starten lässt und man da einfach ein,
ja, ein ein easy Interface hat
was äh sauber zum Smartphone kommuniziert und da ist es, also es ist tatsächlich etwas, was ich mir für die Messenger, die ich tatsächlich nutze, durchaus auch sehr positiv vorstellen könnte, ne, wenn.
Ich hier, ja, eine, äh, eine Kommunikationsinfrastruktur zu meinem Mobiltelefon habe, die mir, die mich über bestimmte.
Zustände oder Zustandswechsel ähm informieren kann. Das ist schon also diese Bot-Funktionalität ist etwas für sich, glaube ich, ja. WhatsApp und.
Signal äh durchaus auch mit guten Gründen gegen wehren. Aber das scheint mir eh so ein bisschen und insgesamt dieses Ding zu sein, dass.
Also das Telegramm tatsächlich so eine Messenger zum.
Also mit diesen Kanälen und mit diesen großen Gruppen für die Öffentlichkeit eher ist als für das Private.
Das ist so, ne, diese Phänomene, riesige Kanäle, folgt mir auf Signal oder sowas, das haben die einfach nicht, ne? Die konzentrieren sich auf Kommunikation zwischen.
Individuen oder innerhalb von überschaubaren Gruppen ähm und sichern dort äh Verschlüsselung und und Privatsphäre in einem Ausmaß, das sie für angemessen halten. Ähm Telegram.
Scheint mir echt immer mehr so ein ja Potenzial zu haben, Twitter-Konkurrenz zu werden.
Also es ist ja ganz einfach schon dadurch so, dass äh Telegramgruppen ähm bis zu zweihunderttausend Mitglieder und Mitglieder haben können, auch ähm Telegram, also auch geschlossene Gruppen, offene Gruppen auch und auf Signal halt nur tausend äh Mitglieder.
Und ist schon alleine da, ist sozusagen der Unterschied, Kanäle können unbegrenzt Mitglieder haben. Der Nächter Kanal, der beim äh bei den Protesten in Belarus so eine wichtige Rolle spielte, der hatte irgendwie eins Komma zwei
hat eins Komma zwei Abonnenten Millionen Abonnenten damals über zwei Millionen.
So, also das sind einfach riesige, das ist ein riesiges Ausmaß. Ich ich würde sagen, es gibt.
Jede Art von Nutzung von Telegram. Also es ich kenne auch Leute in einem Bekanntenkreis, die einfach äh komplett alles auf Telegram an privater Kommunikation.
Machen so wie ich da halt nicht Telegramm für nutzen würde, sondern einen anderen Messenger, aber das ist halt so persönliche,
Präferenz einfach und Telegramm ist dafür natürlich zum privaten Bereich auch absolut in Ordnung, wenn man sich dessen bewusst ist, was man da einstellen kann und und was für einen Messenger man da man da benutzt, eben so als Messenger der Wahl, ähm.
Aber es ist natürlich so, dass diese öffentlichen Gruppen.
Und Kanäle und diese Wortfunktionalität, diese äh Programmierschutzstelle, an die man halt ran kann, schon Telegram sehr unterscheiden von den anderen. Und ähm.
Telegram ist auch einfach einer der Dienste, der halt als wie viele Kommunikationsplattformen gibt's denn, die mit Silicon Valley Diensten mithalten können?
Also es gibt sozusagen äh TikTok.
Und dann gibt's Telegram und dann gibt's WeChat, es gibt noch so ein, zwei andere aber Telekom ist wirklich eine der Dienste, die da mithalten kann, mit offenkundig einer ganz kleinen Zahl von Mitarbeiterinnen, das ist ja auch verrückt.
Ähm das äh sollen ja irgendwie nur, weiß nicht, wenige Dutzend sein, fünfundzwanzig bis dreißig im im Kernteam, das ist ja also verrückt, wenn du dir das vorstellst, wie wenig das.
Ähm zum Maximalinspik von Signal zum Beispiel, der sagt im Gespräch halt auch, dass er äh äh Telegram durchaus sich genau anguckt und die.
Was ich beneidet, wer jetzt vielleicht nicht seine Wortwahl, aber es ist schon sehr spannend findet, was die alles an Funktionen bieten und das auch teilweise als Vorbild einfach sieht, gerade auch für die Benutzbarkeit, für den Spaß, den du damit irgendwie haben kannst, einfach so im Chat.
Und so weiter. Ja, das das ist schon einfach.
Zumindest diese Stickergeschichten haben sie, glaube ich, äh wenn nicht geklaut, dann auf jeden Fall direkt mit Telegramm kompatibel gehalten, ne? Also ich persönlich äh.
Habe äh Signalsticker äh sehr lange äh aus meinem Leben halten können. Aber jetzt habe ich auch einen oder anderen Lustigen.
Aber das kommt ja auch nicht von Telegram mit diesen Stickern, weil du vorhin meintest, da wären sie ja ganz weit vorne gewesen. Das ist doch eigentlich alles aus den asiatischen Messengern, ne? Line on, WeChat und so weiter. Die haben doch, glaube ich, diese Stickergeschichte gestartet.
Das stimmt. Die hatten das auch total früh, aber ähm sozusagen so in der Masse war Telegram schon auch früh dabei und vor allen Dingen mit diesem Customiz Stickern. Ähm den, den wie einfach dir das gemacht wird, also die die Benutzbarkeit ist da auch total hoch.
Also Sticker sind im Prinzip.
Also äh Gifttastaturen, ne, dass man irgendwie, also man hat ein Stickerset, das betrifft zum Beispiel einen bestimmten Themenbereich, da sind ein paar Bilder drin und die ordnet man.
Emotionen oder Emojis zu und kann die dann zusenden. Mir ist das also ich die scheinen irgendwie auf Emojis gemappt zu sein, weil ich sehe, wenn wenn die in der Preview stehen, dann dann kriegt man nicht den Sticker angezeigt, sondern.
Mehr oder minder dazu passendes äh Emoji. Aber äh also genau, es ist irgendwie ein sehr leichtes Format und ich weiß, dass äh mit dem Launch von.
Stickers in Signal eben so der gesamte Reichtum der Telegram-Sticker irgendwie auch darüber gewandert ist. Das muss irgendwie.
Einfach gewesen sein. Aber ja, wie gesagt, ist äh eine.
Eine Datei, ein Dateiformat und eine Kulturtechnik, äh die ich versuche, aus meiner Kommunikation irgendwie rauszuhalten. Dafür brauche ich zu.
Zielgenaue Kommunikation. Ich bin auch sehr erstaunt hier, was da auf die gerade ich habe dieses Telegram-Mediger-Zeit auch, was da durchrauscht.
Ähm kein Wunder, dass die Leute da nach Ritalin fragen, um um das noch alles irgendwie zu verpacken, wie wie schnell diese diese Kanäle irgendwie an dir vorbeiscrollen.
Und wenn du jetzt halt so die Kanäle von den einschlägigen Delikten, die wir vorhin besprochen haben, alle abonniert hast, dann sieht dein Telegram schon ziemlich krass aus. Und natürlich kann man sich auf also so die Q andern Gruppen, finde ich,
auch ein total interessantes Beispiel, weil weil du vorhin sagtest, irgendwie auch Messenger für die Öffentlichkeit, also du hast so diese.
Anderen funktioniert ja darüber, das ist ja so eine Verschwörungstheorie, Verschwörungstheorie zum Mitmachen. Ja und dadurch hat das irgendwie seinen Reiz, dadurch kann jeder sich.
Fühlen und fühlt sich als als etwas Wichtigeres und es gibt halt diese Force Chat äh ähm ja
Funktion von Telegram und so in in so sechzigtausend Leutengruppen, wenn du da zu also zu jedem möglichen Zeitpunkt mal reinguckst, gibt es fast immer irgendeinen Voice-Chat und wenn du da reinhörst, tauschen die sich über die banalsten, persönlichen Probleme aus, gepaart mit irgendwelchen
ähm äh homöopathischen
äh Tipps, gepaart mit irgendwelchen Lichtkriegerdurchsagen, gepaart mit irgendwelchen, hier habt ihr den Q-Drop gesehen. So, also das ist also.
Es ist auch irgendwie erschreckend den Leuten in ihrer psychologischen Verwirrtheit da teilweise zu zuschauen zu können und zu müssen.
Aber es ist halt auch einfach wirklich ja wie 'n Dorf Marktplatz.
Für Gleichgesinnte, die sich da zusammenschalten können mit mit jeder Funktion, mit irgendwie Stickern, mit Voice Chats, mit Nachrichten, mit Kommentaren, mit Votings, mit so allem Möglichen.
Okay. Tja, also wir sehen, du bist auf jeden Fall davon fasziniert. Was ist, es ist, aber du hast äh, also, würdest du sagen, Faszination eher wie so ähm.
Ja wie so ein Unfall oder äh ich denke, dass du schon mehr auch Faszination über dieses Kulturphänomen durchaus.
Erlebst, oder?
Ja äh ja letzteres auf jeden Fall. Also es ist ich ich finde es halt, also,
Uns war es wichtig dadrüber zu berichten, was da passiert ähm dazu zu recherchieren, wer.
Hinter dem Unternehmen steckt und so, ähm weil einfach die die Öffentlichkeit war jetzt mein Eindruck so, außer vielleicht informierteren Kreisen immer so einzeln, weil sie nicht so hildmann ist da und Rechtsextremisten sind da und Impfnachweise kann man da kaufen, da haben ja auch andere
Medien die Zeit zum Beispiel eine super Recherche dazu gemacht ähm,
Aber so das noch mal so einmal so zu bündeln und irgendwie zu zeigen, was eigentlich alles wirklich auf dieser Plattform passiert. Und es geht eben Hand in Hand damit, wie unmittelbar,
halböffentliche bis öffentliche Kommunikation aus deiner Hosentasche da funktionieren kann und was sich daraus entwickelt, sei es von diesen Drogengruppen, über die wir gesprochen haben, ist eben zu diesen Terrorgruppen bis auch zu den.
Gruppen von von äh Demokratiebewegung, das das ist schon einfach total krass und und spannend sich anzugucken.
Und gleichzeitig natürlich auch, ja, habe ich das Gefühl, dass es halt in der Politik überhaupt noch lange nur bedingt angekommen ist in den Ermittlungsbehörden auch irgendwie also man hat Telegramm als Gefahr erkannt, aber ob man sozusagen schon weiß, wie man damit umgehen soll.
Das ist irgendwie schwer zu sagen.
Dann fand ich's halt einfach so krass, dass ein Messenger, der jetzt irgendwie fünfhundertsiebzig Millionen Userinnen, User weltweit haben soll, dass man eigentlich ganz wenig nur über den Chef weiß, der nicht mit den Medien mehr spricht, sondern nur wie so ein,
manchmal über Instagram und seinen Telegram-Kanal kommuniziert,
das ist halt auch krass. Und die Plattform irgendwie in Dubai sitzt aber an der Zentrale niemand anzutreffen ist das ist einfach irgendwie, es ist einfach irgendwie 'ne verrückte.
Einfach verrückt, wenn du dir das überlegst. Man kann jetzt über Facebook sagen, was man will, aber wir wissen einigermaßen.
Sozusagen über das Unternehmen. Wir wissen einigermaßen, was Mark Zuckerberg antreibt. Davon kann man halten, was man will, aber bei Telegram schwer zu sagen.
Wir wissen, wo work sein Auto geparkt hat.
Das genau, das wissen wir auch. Wir wissen auch, welche Sonnencreme er benutzt, wenn er irgendwie surfen geht und da sich irgendwie peinlich fotografieren lässt so, also und er gibt begibt sich auch eine Anhörung, so. Ähm so Pavel Dorow halt nicht.
Was würdest du denn so meinen im im Gesamtblick jetzt auf das, was wir so diskutiert haben, was im Prinzip geschehen sollte? Weil ich denke.
Irgendwas muss hier mal geschehen. Ach so, so wie's jetzt läuft, läuft's zumindest am Rand doch äh extrem schlecht.
Und äh hat so ein bisschen das Potenzial die Gesamtsituation noch weiter zu dramatisieren.
Also das ist jetzt natürlich meine meine persönliche Meinung oder beziehungsweise das das erste glaube ich.
Ist einfach.
Unabhängig von also es ist nicht nur meine persönliche Meinung. Ich finde die Öffentlichkeit muss besser aufgeklärt werden darüber, was Telegramm auch ist. Es gibt diese Missverständnisse darüber und es gibt eben äh,
eine gewisse Gefahr, die aus bestimmten Szenen von Telegramm hervorgeht, wo einfach nicht klar ist, neue Rechte
ähm stoch hastische Terrorismus, der irgendwie jetzt auch viel Telegramm nutzt, wo einfach nicht klar ist, ob das die Behörden und ob sie dafür genug ausgerüstet sind, dass genug aufm Schirm haben, dass da genug passiert. So, das ist das, das ist das eine, das finde ich einfach total.
Total wichtig, dass diese Bedrohung einfach im Bewusstsein.
Dass die Missverständnisse, die die Öffentlichkeit jetzt hat, was irgendwie so diese Sicherheitsfeatures und so über die wir gesprochen haben, dass die auch ausgeräumt ist und jeder halt wirklich danach entscheiden kann, äh da irgendwie gut informiert zu sein und was sozusagen meine persönliche Meinung, was passieren.
Es kann sein, dass das gar nicht so viel vom Staat aus passieren muss. Also ich
Ich glaube, ich habe jetzt so ein bisschen im Urlaub und ich werde auf jeden Fall in der Zeit nicht in Telegram reingucken, da bin ich auch ganz froh, also so sehr fasziniert's mich dann halt doch nicht, aber ich glaube auch nicht, dass es dass es mich oder uns irgendwie in dem ein Rechercheteam von den Kollegen irgendwie ganz loslassen wird, ähm,
Weil das kann sein, dass ich einfach da Entwicklungen jetzt nochmal ergeben, ähm die.
Ein staatliches Eingreifen, was ja das wäre eine Forderung, die man jetzt irgendwie haben könnte. Weiß nicht, es muss irgendwie ein staatliches Eingreifen geben. Man muss irgendwie dem Duo auf habhaft werden, keine Ahnung, wie das funktionieren soll. Das das wären ja so,
die man, ich weiß nicht,
im Ministerium denken Leute sogar drüber nach, dass man Telegramm vielleicht im allerschlimmsten Extremfall, wenn sie jetzt nicht kooperieren, blocken soll, keine Ahnung, wie der deutsche Staat das hinkriegen will, ja? Und was davon zu halten wäre, dass also da ich weiß, was davon zu halten wäre, dass wir höchstproblematisch, so ähm,
Aber wenn Werbefinanzierung passieren soll äh in den Kanälen, wenn Telegram perspektivisch doch irgendwie Geld verdienen muss, dann ist es
immer so gewesen bei großen Plattformen, dass mit Werbepartnern auch eine gewisse ähm Zivilisierung eingekehrt ist
äh erinnert euch an YouTube, wo einfach Werbepartner gesagt haben, das ist kein Umfeld, in dem wir werben wollen und dann YouTube ziemlich schnell agiert hat plötzlich.
Jegliche ähm Hinweise aus der Zivilgesellschaft wurden lange irgendwie.
Weil sie nicht stiefmütterlich behandelt bis langsamer reagiert und als halt die großen Werbepartner gesagt haben, das geht gar nicht hier, äh da ist halt ganz schnell was geschehen und wenn du auf in öffentlichen Kanälen Werbung schalten will, dann dürfte es nicht so einfach sein.
Werbepartner zu finden, die potentiell auch in dem Hildmann Xavier Naidoo, Oliver Jannich-Kanal auftauchen könnten in diesem Werbeumfeld wollen nur wenige stehen, ja?
Weiß nicht, der Kopfverlag hat schon so seine Affiliate Deals aufgegleist, die brauchen dann nicht den Telegram-Werbeplatz, so ähm und ansonsten oder muss man aufpassen, dass man sagt, ne, Verlage, wie der Kopfverlag, könnten das vielleicht sich überlegen zu tun, möglicherweise.
Ähm aber ja das könnte eine Entwicklung sein, die sich ergibt, die vielleicht zu einer.
Also ich ich würde mir einfach wünschen, dass Telegramm mehr transparenter von sich aus,
würde und das ist ja nun was, was äh Social Media Plattform, das hat immer lange gedauert, das darf man ja auch nicht vergessen und Telegram ist.
Riesiges Unternehmen, aber professionelles Unternehmen und mit ähm Personen, die dahinter stehen, die genug Geld und Ressourcen zu haben scheinen
aber es ist auch auch ein Verhältnismäßig junges Unternehmen im Social Media Zeitrechnung immer noch. Das ist natürlich keine befriedigende Antwort, aber wie lange hat es bei Facebook gedauert, bis die.
Anfangen konsequenter und konsistenter gegen strafbare Inhalte auf ihrer Plattform vorzugehen und wir sind heute bei Facebook an einem Punkt, wo man,
Entscheidung auch falsch finden kann, aber es gibt zumindestens mit diesem Overside Board gibt es eine Form von Gremium, wo bestimmte Entscheidungen diskutiert werden. Es gibt einen,
Es gibt eine Community Guidelines, ja, ich weiß nicht, ob ihr euch die mal angeguckt habt, ich werde am Ende auch nicht komplett schlau draus, was ich da schreiben darf und was nicht, aber es gibt immerhin in irgendeiner Form irgendein
umfassenden Regelsatz und nicht nur so ein paar hingeworfene Sachen, wo halt Telegram sagt, okay, keine illegalen Sachen und keinen Kindesmissbrauch und kein islamistischer Terrorismus und so, sondern es gibt ein paar mehr Regeln. Es gibt
gewisse Form von Transparenz über das, was gelöscht werden dürfte und was nicht.
Das würde ich mir einfach wünschen, dass Telegramm vielleicht da auch langsam hinkommt. Die müssen ja nicht dieselbe Position wie Facebook einnehmen. Die können ja auch.
Ähm sagen, okay, hier ist ganz, ganz viel erlaubt und wir ziehen diese Linie an einem anderen Punkt. Das ist eine Frage vor dir. Jede, dir das große Technologieunternehmen heute steht, ja? Und das ist deren gutes Recht, da eine andere äh Linie zu ziehen als andere Unternehmen. Und
manchen Fällen auch sehr positiv. Also weiß nicht, Facebooks antinible Policy ist einfach nur absurd und und prüde und irgendwie.
Aus vielerer Hinsicht falsch. Und es gibt viele Gründe, eine andere Strategie zu wählen als Facebook, aber die irgendwie transparent zu machen und sie zu erklären und sich nicht.
Wie es zu sein scheint, dahinter zu verstecken,
Sitze vermutlich in Dubai bin nicht zu erreichbar, äh bin nicht zu erreichen und für Behörden sind wir nur schwer greifbar und haben ein Konstrukt gebaut. So, also das reicht nicht, wenn du eine Plattform bist, die auch ein öffentlicher Raum ist, finde ich.
Ja und ich finde, das ist etwas, was man zumindest so auf EU-Ebene doch eigentlich locker umsetzen können
müsste und ich frage mich gerade, warum das eigentlich noch nicht so ist. Äh man hat ja gesehen, der Druck über die Plattform Anbieter, also in dem Fall dann halt Apple und äh Google. Funktioniert ja durchaus.
Weil äh Mark Telegramm ein Webinterface haben, aber ich denke mal, in dem Moment, wo
äh die App jetzt nicht mehr runterladbar wäre, äh ist es ja mal ganz schnell vorbei, mit dem Ding, ne? Also das ist ja durchaus schon so ein Hebel, der existiert und in dem Moment, wo man sagen würde, und ich weiß jetzt gar nicht, wie da die Rechtslage ist
hör mal, wenn du hier so und so viel User hast oder 'ne bestimmte Kategorie, müssen wir mal schauen, was was da so der.
Die ja die richtige Metrik auch ist, um um zu sagen, okay, hier wird's jetzt aber auch mal relevant, ne? Aber man könnte ja auch generell sagen, wenn du
Dienstleistung.
Einschränken auf Kommunikationsdienstleistung, aber da wird's ja schon schwierig, ne? Aber so hast du so eine App und du willst jetzt in der EU quasi die Bürgern anbieten.
Und das findet dann eben über die App Stores äh statt. Dann muss es ein Legal enntity geben.
In der EU. Es muss irgendwo ein Büro geben, wo Menschen sind, die äh innerhalb einer definierten Zeit auf Dinge antworten, wenn da der Staat oder irgendein EU-Staat kommt.
Ja, die digitalregulierung kennt dafür ja das schöne Wort des Zustellungsbevollmächtigten.
Und das ist genau das, was das Netz DG verlangt und der Digital Service ist act, ähm der gerade diskutiert wird auf europäischer Ebene, da setzt sich Deutschland zumindest dafür ein, ähm dass äh das Messenger da auch mit aufgenommen werden und,
Sind auch Zustellungsbevollmächtigte vorgesehen.
Genau. Und da würde ich sogar mal fast erwarten, das wird kommen,
So, das heißt, da wird sich dann auch Telegram nicht mehr rausreden können, weil ansonsten sind sie einfach von der Plattform weg, weil der Druck geht dann automatisch auf den Appstore Anbieter und äh Apple ist letzten Endes Telegram dann auch irgendwo egal.
Ja, wobei man bei bei Apple und Google halt sagen muss, so, das ist halt
wenn wir jetzt wenn ich eben gesagt habe, die Transparenz über das, was Telegramm entscheidet, ist, ist irgendwie überhaupt nicht da. Man man kann da nicht reingucken. Das ist eine Blackbox, was die Moderation angeht. Das ist halt bei Apple und Google, bei Apple, aber vor allem auch wirklich genauso.
So, also wir haben mehrfach irgendwie versucht, es gibt sogar eine eine ähm.
Es gibt ja diesen Pala-Fal, wo Apple das mal ein bisschen klarer gesagt hat, warum sie äh eine App rausgeschmissen haben aus dem App Store, aber die Regeln, es gibt zwar einen.
Regelwerk zu dem, was im App Store erlaubt ist und was nicht, aber Apple erklärt das überhaupt nicht,
konsistent und man kann sich ja schon fragen, OK, warum Parla rausgeschmissen und Telegram nicht so? Also, das das ist nicht konsistent und man kann auch diese Paarer Entscheidung aus vielen Gründen irgendwie falsch finden und 'ne krasse Gate-Keeper,
weil Apple natürlich nochmal eine Ebene drübersteht, ne. Wenn Telegram einen Kanal sperrt, ist es halt echt was anderes, als wenn Apple, Telekom insgesamt sperren würde oder Pala insgesamt sperrt. Das ist schon.
Wirklich eine sehr fundamentale Gate-Keeper-Funktion. Und die müssen sich überhaupt nicht erklären.
Und das ist im Digital Service Sekt, soweit ich es sehe, auch nicht groß vorgesehen.
Oder oder nicht, nicht nicht äh vierzig nicht, habe keine große Chance auf Durchsetzung. Das das führt aber perspektivisch uns auch noch viel mehr begleiten. Das hat man ja auch schon gesehen bei,
wie heißt das Unternehmen, dass den anbietet Cloudflair,
als der Betreiber irgendwie aus so einer Lust und Laune praktisch gesagt hat, OK, wir canceln das jetzt für AN nach Christchurch, so, das da kann man politisch mit sympathisieren, aber das war halt auch total so, OK, krass, 'ne Infrastrukturanbieter kann einfach nur sagen, ich bin morgens aufgewacht und hatte keinen Bock mehr,
und dann ähm ähm verändert das sozusagen, ja, mal überschwitzt gesagt und dann verändert das irgendwie die die Machtverhältnisse oder die, die.
Möglichkeiten im Netz. Wir haben halt ein ganz anderes Netz heutzutage, als wir das in den Neunziger hatten, wo.
Möglichkeiten schon echt oft über Geldkeper laufen. Ja klar ist immer wieder auch ans Netz gegangen,
Nachfolgerseite von mit irgendwelchen obskuren und so, aber auch da in Anführungszeichen hat die Plattforming irgendwie funktioniert,
weil ähm die Reichweite dann eben plötzlich nicht mehr so groß war. Und du brauchst bestimmte große Dienste, um eine große Reichweite zu haben und um im großen Stile im Netz mitzuspielen und diese großen Dienste.
Zu wenig dazu verpflichtet sich öffentlich zu erklären finde ich und ich wie gesagt ich find's auch total legitim, wenn die bestimmte,
Haltung und Positionen annehmen, mit denen die streitbar sind, mit denen man nicht zustimmt und so, aber sie müssen sich ja noch nicht mal wirklich erklären dafür.
Das bringt mich äh ein bisschen zu einer Abschluss äh Frage, weil das auch so ein Thema ist, wo wir uns ja auch regelmäßig so ein bisschen die Zähne
beißen, nämlich äh die Frage nach dem Entwicklungsweg für
sag's jetzt mal so salopp, so eine digitale, globale Ethik, ne, also wenn Firmen, solche Entscheidungen
Fällen können sollen oder vielleicht auch gezwungen werden sollen, solche Entscheidungen zu fällen, zu sagen, hier müsst
die und die Regel angewendet werden, um das und das zu verhindern. Ne, also mal so salopp formuliert. Was ist denn jetzt äh quasi der der konkrete Maßstab, was ist denn jetzt wirklich so die die die,
im Idealfall halt weltweit gültige Regel und da wird's natürlich schwierig, ne, die jetzt ein Attila Hildmann davon äh abhält, so einen Kanal zu betreiben.
Das muss sich ja in irgendeiner Form.
Erstmal aus so einem globalen Konsens, den wir sicherlich noch nicht noch nicht haben und wahrscheinlich auch lange noch nicht haben werden, ableiten, ne, oder zumindest aus so einem sehr abstrakten Regelwerk, das.
Vielleicht in irgendeiner Form auf UN-Resolutionen basieren könnte oder soweit was, ne. Was fällt dir.
Ein zu diesem zugegebenermaßen schwammigen Stichwort wohin sich das entwickeln sollte.
Hast natürlich total Recht, das ist echt eine der Fragen, die ihr jetzt immer wiederkehren, ne, mit der Macht der großen Plattform und mit dem.
Wirklichen Schritt vom Internet als Massen.
Kommunikationsplattform irgendwie so durch Social Media, ne? Was kann man im Netz sagen und was nicht irgendwie.
Und und wo verläuft die Grenze, was ist strafbar, wie ist das Verhältnis zwischen Staaten und Tech-Unternehmen und ich finde, entscheidend ist wirklich die.
Transparenz der man die Techno zu zu dehnen, zu zwei Sachen.
Transparenz zu der man Technologieunternehmen zwingt und dann gibt's eine andere Sache, die nur unmittelbar damit zusammenhängt.
Die die auf den ersten Blick gar nicht damit zusammenhängt, aber die die Besteuerung dieser Unternehmen.
Da ist ein neuer Raum entstanden für den Staat, mit dem es dem Staat schwer fällt, umzugehen und äh es gibt,
einfach eine Verzichtfachung von Kommunikationsinhalten und auch auf eine Art und Weise von Straftaten durch den durch den digitalen Raum, aber es gibt eben nicht eine Verzichtfachung der Ressourcen bei den Ermittlungsbehörden,
Und das wäre zum Beispiel eine Möglichkeit ähm kompetente, gut zu bezahlende Cybercrime-Ermittler gibt es einfach nicht ausreichend in Deutschland und.
Ähm,
Ich finde Strafverfolgung ist immer die weniger invasive Variante als Gesetzesinitiativen wie das Netz DG. So und das Netztige ist ja auch total krass. Das zwingt im zweiten Schritt jetzt, ja?
Mit diesem also mit diesem Update, was ab Februar zweitausendzweiundzwanzig greift, das zwingt die großen Social Media Plattformen und nach dem Willen des Bundesamt für Justiz und des Justizministeriums dann auch Telegram.
Nutzerdaten anzuzeigen, proaktiv beim Bundeskriminalamt. Und das Bundeskriminalamt kriegt erstmal all diese IP-Adressen. Das ist auch.
Problematisch, wenn man das auf ein anderes Rechtssystem oder auf einen anderen Rechtsrahmen als zum Beispiel Deutschland übertragen würde.
Kann auch nicht der der richtige Weg sein. Ich glaube, der richtige Weg wäre halt wirklich konsequentere Strafverfolgung, damit's eben nicht so sehr das Gefühl.
Dieses absolut nicht vorhandenen Unrechtsbewusstsein gibt, auf großen Kommunikationsplattformen so ähm.
Dass wir also gezielte wirklich Strafverfolgung, das wäre ein Ding und das andere,
wäre halt einfach diese Unternehmen zu zu Transparenz mir zu zwingen. Also ich würde gerne wissen, was Facebook, Telegramm und so weiter ähm all die großen Plattformen, aus welchen Gründen löschen und was nicht. Es gibt doch,
auch ein Vergleich dazu, es gibt 'ne Gerichtsbarkeit sozusagen für das analoge Leben,
Klar, das ist irgendwie zäh und langsam und so, aber was man
jetzt ähm an politischen Äußerungen oder an an Beleidigungen, an Falschinformationen, zum Beispiel verbreiten darf, äh dafür gibt's ein gibt es Gesetzbücher und dann gibt es Gerichtsurteile, die ich nachlesen kann, wo ich nachgucken kann,
und an dem ich mich sozusagen orientieren kann und die Rechtsprechung kann ich gut finden, die kann ich schlecht finden, die kann ich anfechten, ich kann andere Parteien wählen, die dafür sorgen, dass diese Rechtsprechung sich vielleicht perspektivisch ändert.
So all das ist irgendwie einer demokratischen Kontrolle unterworfen, aber so wie das Netz jetzt in den Händen der,
sozusagen ein Großteil des Netzes dieses Social Media Netz, das nenne ich es jetzt mal, in den Händen einzelner weniger Tech-Unternehmen ist, ist es halt.
Also.
Überhaupt nicht einer demokratischen Kontrolle unterworfen. Die ist aber aus meiner Sicht ins Stück, also ich meine jetzt nicht eine Verstaatlichung dieser Unternehmen, aber es muss eine Transparenz, Ansprüche und zarte,
sozusagen Ansprüche an diese Unternehmen geben können, wenn die nun mal den öffentlichen Diskurs so beeinflussen, wie sie's tun und den öffentlichen Raum so bestimmen, wie sie's tun. So und das fände ich,
halt extrem wichtig und das gerne weltweit und was sozusagen da als strafbar gilt und was nicht, gerne an der äh UN Menschenrechts äh.
Gesetzgebung orientiert, denn die ist ja zum Beispiel auch sehr ähm.
Zensur, die hat sozusagen diese Perspektive mit drin, dass äh in in repressiven Ländern das Netz äh vor allen Dingen als äh Antizensur Werkzeug auch funktionieren kann und dass die Staaten bemüht sind
da eine Zensur zu betreiben und das ist da ja auch mitgedacht. Also ich finde, die Balance ist da zumindest potenziell vorhanden.
Es war auch keine gute pointierte Antwort, ne, aber es ist eine komplizierte Frage, die kann man schwer pontiert beantworten.
Es ist ja, ja, ja, ja, nee, es ist schwierig. Ich finde jeder, jeder Gedankengang äh trägt hier zur Meinungsbildung ein und die ist sicherlich noch lange nicht abgeschlossen.
Aber ich denke, die Sendung ist jetzt äh abgeschlossen. Max, vielen, vielen Dank für deine Einblicke, Einsichten und Erkenntnisse, die du da äh im Rahmen der Recherche der sonstigen äh Auseinandersetzung mit dem Internet gewonnen hast.
Ja, vielen Dank euch für die, für die Einladung und genau,
ähm wollte nur nochmal sagen, auch die Recherche jetzt, über die wir gesprochen haben, ist halt äh im Team beim Spiegel entstanden. Ähm Christina Hebel, Marcel Rosenbach haben ganz viel mit recherchiert und viele andere Kolleginnen und Kollegen.
Ähm ohne die wär's auch nicht, nicht möglich gewesen. Also ähm das, was ich hier an Erkenntnissen geteilt habe, stammt bei weitem nicht nur von mir.
Super. Max, vielen Dank.
Ja, vielen Dank euch.
Viel Spaß in deinem Urlaub von Telegram. Scheint's dir alle Einkäufe vorher erledigt zu haben und ähm dann äh.
Weiß ich, wie ich meinen Sommerurlaub nenne, Urlaub von Telekom.
Danke, dass du dir auch in deinem Urlaub die Zeit genommen hast, dieses Thema nochmal mit uns zu beackern.
Na klar, sehr gerne.
Ich werde jetzt mal ein paar Papierflieger ausm ausm Fenster schmeißen. Das fand ich ja in deiner Story auch so wirklich so ein interessantes äh.
Dass das wirklich das Logo von Telegram, dieser Papierflieger, von dieser Story herkommt, dass sie irgendwann mal gelangweilt, am Fenster saßen und Geldscheine aus dem Fenster geschmissen haben, die dann nicht gut flogen und dann haben sie die irgendwie in Papierflieger umgefaltet.
Ja Tim, aber nun bitte auch nur in Geldscheinen ähm aus dem Fenster werfen, ja und auch gerne testen sozusagen, welcher Geldschein am besten fliegt und so.
Die Größeren, ich ich rate dir zu den größeren Tippen.
Ich probiere das gleich mal aus.
Ja, das ist äh wohl die die einzige wirklich.
Ja, bist halt auch so schön bei dem Logo von Telegram, ne? Das ist halt auch diese Ambivalenza. Das soll sozusagen auch für die Freiheit stehen, ähm hat hat Pavel Durov ja später gesagt, irgendwie von Informationsfreiheit, aber gleichzeitig erinnert es halt auch an diese Geschichte, die halt einfach nur so.
Ja Lehrbuch protziger Internetunternehmer äh schreit, ne? Ähm oder er board Millionär so, aber trotzdem auch ähm ja jemand, der so.
Politisch denkt und weiß ich nicht, der Gesellschaft oder auch dem Staat, in dem er da damals gelebt hat irgendwie gerne mal den Mittelfinger äh zeigt.
Interessant eigentlich, also scheint mir so vom Typ her gar nicht so unterschiedlich drauf zu sein wie äh Kim dot com Kimble
Aber irgendwie scheint ja Glück gehabt zu haben, dass er sich nicht auf Urheberrechtsverletzungen spezialisiert hat. Damit ist er offenbar länger durchgekommen, ne, scheint. Also so von der Fuck You Attitude her tun die sich, glaube ich, beide wenig.
Naja und beide haben sich irgendwie in andere Länder abgesetzt und irgendwie ihr Treiben noch so halbwegs durchzuziehen. Mal gucken, wie lang's mit dem Pavel Doro noch äh äh so funktioniert. Man weiß ja auch immer nicht, was die so für mentale Reisen noch alle antreten so, ne, ne.
Alright. Ich würde sagen, hier machen wir mal einen Punkt und ähm ja, nochmal vielen Dank, Max. Ähm ja und wir haben jetzt die dreihundertneunundneunzigste Sendung im Kasten,
was da jetzt wohl kommt. Wir machen jetzt aber mal keine Versprechung. Ähm,
Leider sind Großveranstaltungen noch nicht möglich, insofern können wir die vierhundert noch nicht im großen Kreis machen, aber ich denke mal, wenn sich alles äh entspannt hat, dann
dafür sorgen, dass es ein bisschen mehr äh Primärkontakt gibt hier mit äh uns und von uns natürlich vor allem zu euch.
So machen wir das.
Genau, ansonsten vielen Dank auch für eure Unterstützung, damit wir hier ordentlich Papierflieger aus dem Fenster werfen können.
Habt ihr doch eigentlich schon ein Event für die äh vierhundertstel Sendung.
Spenden konkret umgesetzt. Ja, genau. Okay, also, wir sagen tschüss und bis bald.
Bis denn, ciao ciao.